[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
i'm ready to go whoo here we are yeah no
intro
i know i thought it feels so weird when
we just come on like that
well we had a lot of [ __ ] we had to do
today anyway i had to do all the shirts
well we did the backs of all this did
the fact that halfway through for all
the people that asked for them recently
it wasn't wasn't enough time to get
everything done but we'll get it done so
i can
probably ship it out tomorrow um yeah
we'll print the fronts tomorrow yeah so
i'll be plugging shirts today if any of
you guys want any [ __ ] shirts
tomorrow is a mailing day
you send me some money i'll send you
sure um
the uh let's see what else is going on i
got this [ __ ] set up
i [ __ ] pulled this thing out now the
microphone isn't on the table
i can now put my drink on the table got
this little pull out thing
yeah you don't have to worry about it so
i got this like a dirty ass towel it's
not really dirty yesterday it's just
[ __ ]
yeah it's there it is dirty it is dirty
yeah it's all right that's to muffle the
sound and i got this over here with my
[ __ ]
it's like a spaceship i got like a
control center for a spaceship
like some [ __ ] out of star trek if star
trek was made by ed wood yeah it'd be
like this that's what i said i said it
looks more like
it's a spaceship and an one movie yeah
i was just asking i was like well what
kind of cake you want tomorrow we always
get the same
he always gets like the same cake like
for his birthday it is real good from
the public space it's a lemon
lemon cake with strawberries on it yeah
it's lemon and strawberry it's really
good
i can order it later yeah we're good
we're going to go to um
koi wan all you can eat chinese cafe
looks like chinese disneyland in there
it's got
a little little artificial
river with [ __ ] little chinese
bridges that go over it and it looks
like you're walking downtown but you're
inside and outside simultaneously it's
like some chinese disneyland
[ __ ] that's pretty good it's a big ass
place got a hibachi and it's got
it's got japanese food and chinese food
add american food
yeah for the kids that don't like it and
a full bar full bar
oh you can eat ice cream or you can eat
sodas
all you can eat sodas oh you could eat
sodas yeah dj meeting said i should get
you a cookie puss
i don't know what a cookie [ __ ] you
don't remember those
nah sounds like a sex toy it sounds like
a sex robot
let me get one of them on my cookie puts
caucasian caucasian edition yeah the
caucasian
caucasian edition the one that looked
yeah no the one with the cat ears
didn't sound like the yeah and it
sounded like some [ __ ] yeah and the tail
tail on it it's like some [ __ ] out of
[ __ ]
anime sorry i just saw
i just saw tristan's screen name what's
this what'd you say
i can't sandra whose breasts are blowing
in the wind
okay awesome awesome breast blowing
where'd she get that did i say that
did i say i think you did [ __ ] man she's
blowing in a wind
he doesn't even remember something i
said when i was sober i can't remember
oh my god so funny to win well that
happens sometimes when these girls go
too hard cowgirl
and they're just jumping up and down on
a [ __ ] [ __ ] just flapping
around they end up being like a fan
keeping you cool underneath there and
everything just yeah you know what i'm
talking about i can turn the fan off
okay i got all the ventilation i need
thank you tila
what tilla said i got tila in the
audience towards your sex bot purchase
yeah happy birthday how much was that oh
[ __ ] she's giving me a 100
thank you very much t did uh yeah how
you been enjoying the movies that i'm
recommending
you know me i have to ask you i gotta
ask how she's doing on her home he's
just gonna have to like nag you
everything until you like do it
yeah let's see what else is going on
there
then uh everybody's wishing me happy
birthday happy birthday
tom and his birthday thank you for my
birthday is actually tomorrow but today
is the birthday party for the public the
public birthday party yeah because we
don't stream yeah
tomorrow well it's like i said i'll go
i'll get you a cake from the
bakery and we'll go to the yeah go to
the koi wine
going to the koi wine yeah i sound like
an old lady
you got the coupons for the koi sandra
said yes i said this i don't i i don't
remember
i remember you said i don't remember the
context but i remember you saying
something along those lines i don't
remember the concept even if you did it
it's like that's
totally sounds like something you would
have said so i
try something probably something in
relation to [ __ ] tube tops or
something
or peanut butter well yeah yeah
maybe that maybe that's sandra's waiting
for her very first peanut butter pie
to be finished peanut butter yeah
actually
i mean honestly probably one of my
favorite things from childhood is peanut
butter fudge
my mom used to make peanut butter fudge
all the time i got a [ __ ] ton of peanut
butter i got to use up
we should make something yeah i got
about six jars of that or peanut butter
different sizes
huh oh yeah we do don't we yeah i gotta
see the thing that happens is that
sometimes we have so much crap
yeah in the um in the pantry in the back
refrigerator
that we forget that we had it so he goes
to the store and then he's like do we
have any more of this [ __ ]
we'll just get some more so sometimes
i'm like why do we have eight things of
salsa in here
yeah but then you know i can use it in
stuff yeah
it still gets used it doesn't usually i
mean it doesn't usually go so we're
going to make peanut butter pie or
peanut butter cookies or something
[Laughter]
i got a bunch of cookie stuff i got a
bunch of cookie stuff we should actually
probably make some peanut butter cookies
yeah i mean that'd be really good
they're good tila said uh
she saw episode number one of spartacus
okay yeah what do you think
uh intrigued enough to keep going yeah
yeah the first one is
like pretty good um it gets like much
better from there on out
right as soon as he becomes enslaved and
he ends up in the ludus
the first one was just kind of all set
up like from there on out it gets like
way way better like the first one's good
but it's not
yeah the first one the first one you're
not sure what kind of series this
is but then when you get into it you're
like oh all right and it gets deeper and
deep
you start binging it yeah because
because
you got to find out what happens next
zach says happy birthday
tyler says yo happy birthday to tom keep
hitting those weights juicy tom is best
tom
oh man he does something you're juicy
[Laughter]
juicy and moist yeah it's gonna uh oh
and uh thank you no need for me too
i won't acknowledge someone's age oh
it's all right no i'm old
well i'm old but i'm getting better man
i'm looking in the [ __ ] mirror and i
go oh man i look so [ __ ] hot i can't
[ __ ] believe this [ __ ] i come out of
the shower i'm not used to it i'm going
to
have sex with myself that's good i said
jenny get the camera
bring that measuring tape you're just oh
my god i haven't brought the measuring
tape out again you haven't no
the last time i was thinking about that
every time you get out of the shower
it's like [ __ ] buffalo bill up in
there would you [ __ ] me i'd [ __ ]
no she's making sure i'm uh
that's what i'm thinking you're nothing
well seeing how the progress goes
seeing how the progress goes last i
measured i got 17-inch guns i'm gonna
try to get them [ __ ] up to like 21.
that's gonna take a few years but we'll
see we'll see how it goes sandra said i
discovered something awesome on the
internet we have a german peanut butter
shop
you get everything there all the brands
you talked about oh
there's a whole peanut butter shop see
that [ __ ] there's enough people in
germany they understand either germans
or expats
that want peanut butter that sustains a
shop that has all different peanut
butter
that's right uh activities and products
yeah
tequila was mexico's gift to the world
peanut butter was america's gift to work
yeah
the south that's actually that's the
south that did that
there's a lot of [ __ ] you're welcome
world we're welcome you're welcome
[Laughter]
yeah that was george washington carver
that came up with that [ __ ]
like i said when i was at the wax museum
in st augustine there was a wax figure
of him which was actually one of the
better ones
i thought that was pretty cool i think i
think i took a picture of it i took
pictures of pretty much all of the uh
wax figures in there
yeah uh tila said wait a minute the
actor died in spartacus
yeah yeah i think after the second
season
was he in the first two seasons in the
first two seconds the third season is a
new guy
yeah but you get used to it real quick
after a couple episodes yeah because it
was a little i was a little weirded out
but yeah he died real young
guy died of cancer yeah nothing it was
leukemia wasn't it
blood cancer bone marrow cancer
something like that i can't remember
yeah it was like ridiculous you'll see
as the season goes on in that second
season um and i don't remember how much
of the he was in the second
he was in the second season but not a
lot i don't think was he well no he
wasn't in the second season because that
was a prequel
yeah it was a prequel remember it was
about batiantes he's getting
he he looks really good at the beginning
of the sea of the of the seas and
towards the end of the season you go
like is he getting smaller yeah he was
getting smaller
cancer was killing him he couldn't keep
that physique
you're gonna like that [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you liked 300
you like real good like uh action dramas
a bunch of intrigue bunch of dirty
tricks and [ __ ] plus lots of gore
lots of gore lots of sex i enjoyed that
lots of sex in it lots of degeneracy and
[ __ ]
and and a bunch of little like kind of
like morality tales
or it it's a good it's a good series
thank you very much esther
what'd you say happy birthday eve tom
your presents are headed your way
tomorrow for you oh [ __ ]
thanks i know i already know what they
are i got sophie's presents uh
today and yesterday but i'm not gonna
bust him out until till
till time comes i mean i'm i'm really
excited about this
i'm really excited about this well
because that shit's gonna be inspired
and then i [ __ ] come out with that
[ __ ] i'll know when the time is right
i'm like super happy because it was like
way
it was way cooler than what i was
expecting yeah
yeah that could be cool um what else was
i saying about
about spartacus and here's another thing
that about about spartacus is that
overall
the major part of the story arc
spartacus the slave revolt and then what
happened once they escaped and
everything
is actually in general historically
accurate so far
i haven't finished season four yet but
a lot of the names are the same and a
lot of things a lot of it really
happened
all the little small details about the
intrigue between gladiators and [ __ ]
there they made that up but no that
slave revolt did happen and spartacus
and and abandoned damn run run renegade
slaves and gladiators
fought the roman empire i think they
were they were free for a couple years
before they finally got him
yeah well they were like wondering yeah
and he ended up being like a legendary
boogeyman
that spartacus to come and get you [ __ ]
one thing that i've noticed that was a
little bit different is that
they're universally shown as kind of
like
uh heroic and kind of like saving
people that's not really historically
supported
once they got free there was a lot of
rape and pillaged i mean they they
showed
no mercy uh to the roman people they
weren't romans a lot of them
they came from other places so they were
just getting vengeance on everybody
and it didn't have anything to do with
uh spartacus wasn't
it didn't have anything to do with
politics it's not like he was out there
trying to like
free the slaves or stop the practice of
slavery in rome
no he didn't give a [ __ ] he just ran
around [ __ ] raping burning murdering
killing um but
think about it they they were basically
captured foreigners wouldn't you do the
same
well no but yeah i would
i would if you enslaved me and [ __ ]
took me to a foreign land i'd [ __ ]
kill everybody
especially if we were in a big horde i'd
punish the entire nation
and that was the the the way people did
[ __ ] back then
mass punishment no i wouldn't do it
that's what they did
because it just seems like well you're
not a man well yeah i know yeah man
and also i'm not a terrible person yeah
well they were
they were gladiators for a reason yeah i
know yeah
but no they punished the the general
population
anarchy extras do do you ever review new
paul nashee movies we haven't yet
but uh i would like to eventually like
because i have my own little movie
review show so i might do some on there
i was thinking about it the other day
actually
zach was asking he said he drunk he
drank a [ __ ] ton and then his did he say
his knuckles swelled up
and was that like unusual i don't know
what he's talking about that sounds
pretty interesting
i've never heard of that zach oh uh red
mage
thank you red mage 848 a little piece of
birthday cake thank you for 1.49 thank
you
maybe now i'm excited about the cake
yeah cake's coming
i wrote it down i'm gonna go to that
[ __ ] actually i'm more excited about i
mean i like the cake's gonna be great
but uh i'm more excited about koi won we
haven't been to a chinese buffet in
forever
since this damn pandemic thing that's
now open so
yeah i checked the website and it said
that it was
that the dining room was i'm gonna take
pictures of it and i'll post it in tom
shitty's movies maybe we'll put it in a
stream on instagram or something
so you guys can see yeah you could take
maybe i'll make a little video make a
video if you with a big pile of shrimp
in front of you yeah we'll put that [ __ ]
in the [ __ ]
or something put that [ __ ] in the stream
we'll see you hold on let me
gotta cool my hair granthar's hammer
said that's gout it might be
yeah yeah
i don't know i have pains in my feet
sometimes and i thought about that too
i'm like maybe i have gout that's still
like old school
i was reading that um the book that i
just read the dan simmons one the fifth
heart that was about uh henry james and
stuff
i did a review of it i put it up a
couple days ago and uh henry james
and i'm guessing this is historically
accurate he also had gout that was like
such a 19th century
dude disease i guess because they just
like sat around and
ate rich food yeah i don't know
i don't think that's the only thing that
causes it but that seems like that was i
that's and he was kind of like a hefty
fella
so you know i don't know
yeah uh zach says i just read on google
that for some people drinking a lot can
cause inflammation but it went away for
me it was weird
yeah it's like i guess i guess i can see
that i don't think i've ever had that
happen to me particularly
zach who's yeah who's his knuckles
swelled up
yeah after drinking a lot it's all that
beating your meat man
like that [ __ ] star swelling with you
know the shake weight stop
stop molesting yourself man but yeah uh
yeah t
uh old boy died it was kind of a shame
she goes he's a fine looking man yeah he
was replaced with another final looking
man though
and it does kind of after a couple
episodes you just kind of get used to
that guy
yeah because i think what happened was
we watched the first two seasons and we
were like man that's awesome and then we
started watching the third one i'm like
i can't i tell you i feel really bad but
i can't get used to the new guy i knew
the first guy who died
yeah but i was kind of like i can't get
used to this guy's like it's freaking me
out
and um then i think we just stopped
watching it and also it had been a long
time it's been a long time
and we kind of forgot what i'm like wait
who is this now i forgot
like i forgot what happened with this
yeah so we took a second run at it
yeah and then a couple of couple
episodes into it i was like yeah okay
this
this is the the spartacus then yeah i
got more into it because the when we
re-watched it this last time
yeah we watched them like much closer
together right another thing is season
two is a flashback
yeah all right and it's actually in some
ways better than season one
honestly flashback is pretty [ __ ]
good i think we talked about this before
but it's like i'm not really sure
if they did the second season as
flashback just because they knew that
guy was dying and he would be able to
come back or if it might have been just
because batiatas
was so popular i think both that they're
like okay
we need a back story about him and like
xena warrior princess nobody
getting loose because lucy lawless was
in a table and it's like because those
two are like the best characters
yeah yeah yeah t if you've only seen the
episode one you haven't met body
odysseus is like the
he's the owner of the ludus which is the
damn gladiator prison school
that they have and he's he's he's
spartacus slave master you go
you're going to see it's [ __ ] bad ass
he's a good dude
and his wife is played by lucy lawless
well he's a good dude in the way that a
roman would be a good roman
in other words [ __ ] treacherous he's
[ __ ] very good
trying to move up it's a good word for
him he's trying to move up
he's trying to move up and he's trying
to do it but everyone sucks so it's
almost kind of like you
you're kind of like rooting for him a
little bit even though he's a [ __ ]
everyone else is like
bigger [ __ ] too bigger [ __ ] and they're
treating him bad
yeah they're treating him bad and he and
he and he's trying to move up in the
[ __ ] roman society
they're treating him like [ __ ] and he's
just got to ruthlessly [ __ ] move his
status up higher it's all about status
it's pretty good he's kind of doing it
for his wife too because some weird [ __ ]
happens with his dad and everything like
that his dad wants him to divorce his
wife
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool and
that's kind of one thing is he does
he he does like really genuinely love
his wife and they are kind of like
working out as a team because she's just
as treacherous and intelligent as he is
yeah
so she's working one angle and he's
working another angle yeah
so it's kind of like i was kind of into
that like i said that you know they're
terrible people but everybody else is a
terrible person and are like worse than
they are
yeah so you know what i mean well being
terrible and being bad was a different
dynamic well that's what yeah that's
what i'm saying so it was all relative
it's all relative it's very much kind of
like
you were kind of expected to be
loyal to your friends but be real
ruthless to your enemies
but to make examples out of people
that's how the society was held together
it was like one big mafia so it's kind
of like a mafia movie
it was very naturalistic it's all about
who was the most dominant and it's a
hierarchy
and how to get status and
how to deceive people and then how to be
loyal to people there was loyalty he was
a good
man by roman standards
which was just really should win at all
cost that's really how they kind of
and they were they were like that
another thing is is that they just
weren't
you weren't supposed to murder people
but they all did it
yeah the more rich they were the more
powerful they were
the more people they murdered including
people in their own family
it was almost like you had to do it
because the other people in your family
were obstacles
were holding you back you'll see yeah
you'll see you know it was a bunch of
[ __ ] and
this is uh
you know roman history [ __ ]
demonstrates it over and over again that
that's that's how they were
also the outfits and the wigs were
really outstanding yeah and and the set
yeah it's just a beautiful looking yeah
especially like i said when they get
into the more like
upper class yeah you know romans and
everything like that sort of like all
their fabulous outfits and wigs and
everything
yeah and if you're an american parties
if you're an american you can go back
into american history and see when they
when they started this experiment
um it was all part of the enlightenment
and they were trying to get a happy
balance between a roman system which is
a republic
and a greek system which was a democracy
they were trying to
work it out like that so you can see a
lot
and a lot of them a lot of america is
kind of like what you're going to see
here um because of the form of
government
and um of course all all governments
over time become corrupt
and senile and this is happening in this
too in this
movie you'll in that series you see it
and it's
part of human nature which that's one
thing i like about it you know what i
mean you can't
fight what people are and power corrupts
people
and it gets into that
actually the best people are the slaves
they don't have any power
until they escape yeah
yeah uh zach asked jenny have you seen
the movie about agatha christie starring
vanessa redgrave and dustin hoffman it
sounds familiar but i probably have not
seen it
seems like something you'd like it does
actually sound like something i'd like
so i'd have to like look that up
um let's see lucy lawless who played
xena is married to
robert tappert that's why she got the
gig in the evil dead series as well
oh and if you haven't seen ash versus
evil dead everybody needs to watch that
just
i mean where else can you see
bruce campbell get his face stuck in a
corpse's [ __ ]
yes great i mean come on but it's the
best
but in spartacus you can see in
spartacus you can see
basically soft x [ __ ] sex scenes
it's very [ __ ] and very gory with lucy
lawless and she looks fantastic
she was she does look like she's
probably about 50 at the time huh
may her 40s are fit 40s or early very
early 50s yeah she
and she looks fantastic everybody looks
fantastic in the damn
thing well yeah they want everybody to
look like all the gladiators are [ __ ]
oh they're they're all [ __ ] looking
great and [ __ ] you can tell they're
[ __ ]
trting their asses off through that
whole [ __ ] thing
hit by a storm if we lose the stream you
guys know it's because
of the the oh florida never change
yeah i like the rain though i just don't
like when it knocks the power out all
the time because i mean in the summer it
does this pretty much every afternoon
yeah
so that's all you see you can't really
do much about it
don the bomb said the second season was
made as everyone thought the main actor
was going to survive
well that makes it even sadder okay so i
guess they just did do it as a prequel
just because everybody liked batiata so
much
and and his wife i can't remember what
her character's name was
i just called her lucy lawless the whole
time
because they were like i said they were
i mean spartacus was cool and everything
but it's like this
and i liked all the intrigue but those
two were the best characters
and um the da tori the guy that was
training the uh
the gladiators he was also quite awesome
yeah
and he gets kind of like a lot of uh
screen time too
i can't remember what his real name was
everybody just called him dautori donald
was saying what about when rome became
an empire i'm not really sure there's no
context to the question
it's you have make sure that if you guys
ask me a question
make sure you kind of give me enough
background so i can answer it i don't
know what it mean what about when it
became an empire i don't know what
you're talking about
it became an empire after the
assassination of julius caesar
and his nephew uh um
octavian took over and renamed himself
uh what was it
um
man i can't remember either [ __ ] i just
i've had it
i had it on the tip of my tongue i
thought i forgot it that was during the
roman civil war
thing is is that rome actually ran
better as an empire
in a certain way uh the citizens didn't
like it because
a representative government just kind of
vanished but that's probably happened
here now
according to you know actually
there's probably no representative
recover government here at the federal
level it's probably been that way for
several decades
because tulane university did a whole
damn study on
how many times the senate actually
passed a law that the people supported
and it hasn't happened in a long long
time it's mostly supporting
transnational corporations so the people
don't control the government
the corporations and the oligarchs
control the federal government
it's very corrupt it was like that in
rome too when it was an empire i thought
i heard pookie coming here nothing right
i guess not
yeah so you know this is all something
sorts out through the
evolution of governments which um
government's a [ __ ] trick it was
something just that technology
required it um but governments will
never do right by you or
propagate any kind of freedom if you
look at if you look at history
the good things in the world and freedom
didn't happen because of government
it happened because of technology
technology ends up freeing the people
not governments so hopefully if
technology
continues to evolve it will make things
like governments obsolete
when that happens then you have to worry
about it every person can
do whatever they want to do without
[ __ ] over other people that much or
if they do [ __ ] over
the people they'll be punished so
let me just look at the internet
everything's decentralized it's become a
network society and that's the greatest
thing
for human liberty you do not want
centralized control
because you'll never like who inherits
that control it'll bounce from one
[ __ ] to the next and you can't please
everybody
so every time something's centralized
the people will be unhappy
decentralization is the future
something i didn't realize until i was
watching
and this is like a funny way to like
learn about this piece of information
but we had rented uh because you know we
really like jeremy ray
jeremy wade right he does like river
monsters so he has a [ __ ] ton of other
shows like i said he's the gordon ramsay
of fishing
so he had another show called mysteries
of the deep and we rented the first
season
of that i don't know if there's other
seasons but we watched the first season
and one of the things that he talked
about on there was that
pretty much night what they say 90 of
global communications
internet financial transactions
everything uh
you think it's like bouncing off
satellites and [ __ ] like that but it's
totally not
it goes through cables that are run on
the bottom of the ocean
okay uh so they were kind of talking
about how
you know if there was you know like a
solar flare or something like that
how it could kind of like wipe out a
whole bunch of [ __ ] and i was like
that's nice
yeah okay dom clarified his question he
wanted to know
what i thought about rome becoming an
empire how it became an empire
well there was a bunch of different
factors um
but i would say probably the main thing
that happened was is that
rome got into a long war with carthage
and
during that time it it promised its
soldiers
uh land so it could um so when they
retired
they could retire as farmers i think it
was after 20 years of service each
but before that before they had finished
their service
all these veterans basically the the
roman elites and the rich people brought
up
all the damn farmland that they were
going to give what give away to all of
those veterans
and who the and then they bought a bunch
of slaves and put
them on those farms
to to to to grow food so by the time the
veterans were
were retiring their promise was broken
there was no farms for them to go on
they couldn't compete against slave
labor
so they insourced they insourced all the
damn labor to slaves
and the veterans had nothing
and this caused a populist uprising
which ended up into a civ ended up in a
civil war there were roman armies
fighting inside the capital
during the civil war um
you know was right after the civil war
julius caesar was assassinated and
octavian took over and octavian was an
emperor
and he basically betrayed everybody and
streamlined it down into an empire that
served the oligarchy
or the rich roman citizens and the
veterans got [ __ ]
that's really kind of in a nutshell kind
of how it happened but there was a bunch
of other stuff
that had happened a lot corruption was
part of it cultural corruption
uh the system the republican system of
rome had started to become kind of what
they called a reach senility
its uh institutions were too corrupt to
get anything done
it was just it was it was a [ __ ]
but uh turned into an empire in general
because
the roman republic got corrupt and was
[ __ ] over its own its own people so
you had to rule [ __ ] by force
that's that's what it boils down to when
they [ __ ] you over
you get pissed when you get pissed you
rise up when you rise up
they bring in a dictatorship and it's
that same pattern
throughout history over and over and
over again
so it's like a life cycle
but one thing one thing though
as a dictatorship rome achieved more as
a dictatorship as it
than it did a republic dictatorships are
superior to republics in certain ways
when it comes to performance
because they just keep pushing and
pushing and pushing they get [ __ ] done
you don't like it they just [ __ ] kill
you
and they just keep pushing and pushing
and pushing they're dangerous
but they achieve high goals and then
they eventually people get sick of it
and falls apart
you will accept as much dictatorship as
you will
tolerate that's the lesson
if you will tolerate this much then
that's what they'll give you if you
tolerate this much then that's what
they'll give you they'll
have you balls to the walls maximum as
much as they can ask for
that's what they do tila says thunder
sounds loud y'all yeah it is it is
really it's right outside there
it's right yeah yeah the windows like
that's right there um
yeah and they were talking about uh
other series where the main
character died or the main actor died
and they had to replace him and somebody
pointed out um
yeah john ritter eight simple rules for
uh dating my daughter yeah i remember
that
and he died during the filming of that
zach says uh
i know you love the modern day but
what's a time period you would want to
live in
if you could ooh zach asked me that
that guy says okay i don't know if i'd
want to go back too far
if i could i don't know man man i don't
know i do fine in the 40s
i wouldn't mind going to world war ii i
mean i wouldn't mind
maybe like i don't know
late 19th early 20th century i could
probably hang with that
but earlier than that [ __ ] it ancient
egypt would be a trip
now yeah it's like prior to that i don't
i wouldn't want to live in the middle
ages or anything like that i don't
i mean you want to live somewhere where
it was at the height of its
where it was at the height of its
civilization where they at least had
like
you know because if you even ancient
rome in ancient egypt it's like they
mostly kind of had their [ __ ] together
kind of
in rome what would have happened if you
were rich in rome
you would have had good [ __ ] sex
parties where people were actually
[ __ ] shaved
okay so you had to worry about body hair
they weren't into that they worked out
they looked that's good
that's his main like criteria for what
it's like
they took showers and [ __ ] we're not bad
but baths they cleaned up
yeah because see middle ages everyone's
already filthy and dirty and covered
with scabies and whatever yeah
uh you wouldn't have liked ancient roman
food though it was
nasty see i don't like i i don't know
like i know
people like to like piss and moan about
oh back in my day it's like [ __ ] that
it's like i would much rather live
nowadays
and i really would i'd be very reluctant
about go
having to go back some plate time before
electricity yeah like before there was
air conditioning unless i could move
somewhere
where the where the weather wasn't an
issue if i had to stay in florida no way
i'm not staying here without [ __ ]
arrogance nope
i don't like it now in ancient rome you
could eat bread you could eat fish and
you could eat meat i would stay away
from all them damn sauces
okay anything that they call any kind of
sauce seeing the recipes you don't want
to know that
rotten fish guts in them and stuff you
don't want any of that
okay no i don't want it yeah put some
garum on that you know no thanks
olive oil olive oil yeah i'll take that
take some olive oil
take some wine yeah but you'd be eating
real simple
stuff you wouldn't want to know what was
in the real advanced [ __ ] from what has
survived it's like
oh you eat that you know
and uh they didn't know what they were
poor people would just take a damn mouse
and break its neck put it in olive oil
and swallow it and then wash it down
with a [ __ ] wine
that was how they hey meats meat meat
that's how they got meat
the version of a burger and fried being
poor has sucked forever
yeah it's like oh boy here's my third
mouse of the day
i love my life well they got a fast
representative cycle you could raise a
lot of them very quickly
and it's protein and they just swallow a
whole mouse with the [ __ ] fur on it
and everything
that was their version of a burger fry
put hair on your chest
yeah and then you took some roll up
lettuce and eat that
there's some olive oil on it oh man yeah
and they didn't chew you weren't gonna
chew that mouse well i don't think i
would like to chew an
uncooked mouth that might be a little
nasty yeah
i don't even know how you could swallow
the whole thing whole you'd probably
choke
well they they dipped it in olive oil so
deliberately
they swallowed it like a big old pill
i think i'd rather just like dive
starvation things
and when you see some of those pictures
of rome you know what i mean they're
ancient rome they show all that statuary
and it's all like marble and white and
classic that [ __ ] was painted it should
look tacky as [ __ ]
like out of a damn persian nightclub
and then they'd [ __ ] they didn't that
makes me happy yeah they paint the pubic
hair on that [ __ ]
and then they'd [ __ ] hopefully they
made it wouldn't it be cool if they had
painted
like rainbow pubic hair on the ship
and the skin is like yellow and straight
like tiger stripes and [ __ ] like that
it's like look how [ __ ] fabulous that
[ __ ] is no that [ __ ] looked real classy
and [ __ ] white but that's not how
that's not how they looked at it
evidently there's traces of paint on it
on that angst and stuff everybody's like
oh my god these were like totally picked
up
yeah and then they uh you know
at least during certain periods i mean i
know they broke in
they broke into the roof of a of a uh a
theater one time that had been buried
they buried it on purpose and it still
had
statues of important people they were
not sure who they were because they
weren't
they're not named because they weren't
that important clearly because we didn't
remember who they were
no i think i think they were very
important to the romans
they didn't require any names because
you would instantly recognize no i'm
just saying that the fact that we didn't
know who they were means they weren't
all that important in the long run
uh no it's emperors i think
just that there's a lot of problems with
like they'll show you a dam
in some of these museums they'll show
you a picture of somebody and they would
this especially back in the 50s and 60s
and stuff they'd show
this is this is emperor augustus you
find it no it's not augustus
they you know that's octavian well yeah
they don't know they don't have pictures
they have pictures of them right they
don't know which ones which not octavian
they're just like guessing
yeah i can't remember which one it was
it was
it was one of octavian's descendants uh
um fl it was flavius but they thought it
was they thought it was augustus but it
was flavius
so they you know you know it's an
emperor by
the uniform he's wearing usually they're
wearing some kind of a military type
uniform
that is a ceremonial armor so you know
it's a
it's an emperor but you just don't know
which one because you know what i mean a
lot of times they weren't
there's no inscription yeah but i think
they have most of them straightened out
now
like especially from like the giulio
claudians i'm getting too complicated i
think people don't know about that but i
think
they knew what the julia claudians
looked like well yeah they had a very
distinctive
uh they had a distinctive look to them
but uh yeah i was gonna say yeah this is
emperor calapegeous
if anybody has uh watched mst you know
what i'm talking about so uh yeah gram
there's hammer is saying no toilets
yeah everyone used chamber pots imagine
having an outhouse in your living room
that's another thing
you definitely would not want to go back
to a time
before see i just wouldn't want to they
had public toilets
yeah but and they would sit down next to
each other and talk i don't even conduct
and it didn't flush it was just like an
open pit and then when you stood up
[ __ ] some dude was sitting there with
a damn stick with a bunch of
wet rag on which they show in spartacus
sit there and clean your ass he was like
yeah okay all right then you block off
this like row of like a wooden bench
with like holes in it
and you just kind of sit there like
taking a [ __ ] like hey hey brian what's
up
blah blah blah and then like then you
stand up and there's like wiping your
ass
yeah okay cool bye then they take the
ass wiper and stick and put it back in
the bucket of water that came from just
swish it around a little bit be all
right and then use that on the next dude
i'm gonna be ill it's no wonder that
they didn't get [ __ ] sick all the
time but i guess
i guess they had real strong immune
systems well they must because they're
probably like uh you know
they grew up in that environment but
like i said if you guys uh i know i've
mentioned this book before and i think
somebody
uh said that they had read it but
there's a really good book called the
ghost map
where they talk about um uh there was a
big like cholera outbreak
in london back in the 1800s and that was
kind of the main
impetus for them discovering that hey if
you [ __ ] in the water
and then drink the water then maybe
you'll get sick and die
yeah uh and it was sad because it's like
one doctor
figured it out like by um pinpointing
that it's like hey everybody that you
know drank from this particular water
spigot
got sick and that was the one that was
right near the like the sewage pit
yeah and so he kind of like just figured
out oh there must be like something in
the water that's making everybody sick
and everybody thought that he was uh
crazy yeah
so you know all right there's some stuff
that they're talking about yeah rome had
had running water rich people had
faucets and stuff
they had water in the house to be
delivered it'd be a pool in the middle
of the damn house
where the rooms joined uh they also had
baths
uh the thing is they didn't have flush
toilets flush toilets happened later
um late 1800s i think um
but uh but they did have running water
and they did have a sewage
system to take [ __ ] away
but i think you had to use i think you
think you went to the bathroom in a pot
if they were in their house and then
they dumped it into the sewage system
that would take it away
it didn't flush i don't believe now
they also have put the each little block
kind of had a damn
if you were in a rich neighborhood had a
public bathroom you could walk down
there
and they also have public baths which
are kind of like going to the pool
and evidently they were extravagant you
know some of them had hot water and
someone had cold water and they would
like jump from the hot to cold
they had like a shower thing that you
showered off first before you went into
the damn pools of water so that's
that's quite modern you sat out there
and you
you get tweezed or shaved they did both
and get your hair cut
tweeze me yeah and you could get blown
or getting jerked off
yeah you get blown or get jerked off by
boys or girls they have a little menu on
the wall
and people work you know people working
there you know blowing
or sex or whatever yeah it's just like
going to the car wash where you get like
the deluxe
it's me maintenance you get tweezed and
plucked then you have a blow job you get
this that's the other thing
it's like anywhere clothes it was all
nude and
and what was funny is while all this
shit's going on they're little kids
running around
there was no problem with sex in front
of little kids and having sex with kids
they they didn't
seem to have a problem with that uh no
they did not no it's just that you
didn't want to have sex with kid
with some kid that was the the the the
child
of someone of a much higher status than
you you'd be punished
they had to which is so funny that's the
only thing you get in trouble for
not the fact that it was just an actual
child no just that they were from a
higher
ranking family yeah because everything
was hierarchy
and uh no problem with having sex with
some of the lower ranking family they
couldn't say anything about it
yeah what are you gonna do and it was
kind of the way it was with wives though
too yeah if you were of real
high status
you could just [ __ ] somebody's wife
there's nothing you could say about it
i mean you could say stuff like under
your breath but that was about
it an emperor would go up and just
demand i'm taking your wife
and he there's all kinds of reports
about it was not good behavior
people didn't like it was considered to
be dishonorable but they did it anyway
they'd take some dude's wife and then
after he's not
after he [ __ ] knocked her up and
they're knocked her up knocked some
boots with her whatever and
got what he wanted come back to the
dinner table and tell everybody how good
or bad she was
with her husband's sitting right there
stay classy romans
yeah so i remember who that was it was
doing that might have been caligula
it was well and that wouldn't even be
the worst of caligulas no it is but
that sounds like well we did a show
about caligula yeah
and i'm pretty sure that like he did
that kind of [ __ ] but that wasn't even
like if that didn't even register
because of all the horrible other [ __ ]
that he did
if if he actually did it it's hard to
know what well it's hard to know because
it was a long time ago
yeah and all their history was fake news
basically
the history was whatever you were hired
to write
you know tomorrow well and sometimes
stuff that survived and like i said we
don't have like sometimes stuff that was
written at the time that might have been
more accurate has been lost subsequently
so we don't really know you know no two
roman history books agree
yeah everyone was different and it had
to do with
whoever got hired to write that history
book you couldn't [ __ ] say anything
bad about the present emperor or any of
his families
and and you couldn't say anything good
about the enemies of his families
so history changed how roman history was
changed depending on who emperor who the
emperor was
yeah no fake news it was all fake so you
can kind of glean maybe
what happened but not real well and
only only time you'd ever get something
that was kind of straight out of them
is if it was something that a lot of
times these roman historians are writing
about something that happened in roman
history 200 years prior you know
yeah and then he his sources were
already contaminated because they were
they were erased in their own history
depending on what
dynasty was in charge it's myth i think
a lot of it i think
i think the names and the dates are
correct
maybe major events were correct but the
reasons and the political explanation is
probably all wrong
i mean i feel like the closest you can
get to
objectivity is if for example
um there were lots of different accounts
of one person or one battle or something
like that from lots of different
places lots of different historians
from different areas some of which had
no dog in the fight
yeah that's awesome foreign so yeah so i
kind of feel like
you have to read so many different
sources just to kind of get a handle on
yeah but you know historians know that
because you know
and like i said a lot of stuff has
subsequently been lost also archaeology
trumps history
a lot of history doesn't match up with
the archaeology you dig it up and you go
well no i could that couldn't have
happened
yeah because i mean there's it is proof
right there it's just what they're
saying didn't happen because there's the
proof
so that reminds me that another thing
that i learned
from memories of the deep uh or
mysteries of the deep brother the jeremy
wade show was that i didn't realize
you guys know like the dan simmons book
the terror then they made that
into the miniseries which was actually
really good
and it was about the franklin expedition
you know the
the hms terror the hms erebus and then
they went looking for the northwest
passage and then they disappeared
and blah blah blah and it's like so they
didn't find the ships until
i didn't realize that they had found the
ships they found them in what 2017 i
think they said or two yeah a couple
years
back yeah it was only like a few years
back they actually found the ships just
sitting there
at the bottom of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
arctic or whatever and actually
when they found the ships and they went
and dug up
the three because you know how when they
uh you know they went around the site
and they found those three graves of
like the dudes from the franklin
expedition that had died and they had
like erected gravestones for them
and they dug them up and they were like
super well preserved like they even show
the picture on the thing and i was just
like holy crap he looked like he just
fell asleep or whatever
and so they did like all this um stuff
on their bones
because they wanted to determine and i
think dan simmons talked about this in
the book and they talked about this on
the show as well
that they think that the reason that
some of them resorted to cannibalism
because they know that they did
even though they had food on the ship
they had three years worth of food
on the [ __ ] chip so they couldn't
figure out why they started like eating
each other
and also there was like a tribe of inuit
that was like trying to help them and
said hey we tried to give them like seal
meat and they wouldn't eat it so i don't
know what the [ __ ] is
the problem and so they were like what
the [ __ ] was the matter with them
and for a long time the theory was
that they had all gotten lead poisoning
from
the canned goods that they had put in
the ship like to store it for the
expedition
so they decided since since that was
kind of and they went into that on the
terror too
i think that was kind of like the main
um the main explanation that like
everybody was like going like losing
their [ __ ] because they were all getting
lead poisoning from the cans
and so that since that was the main
theory
for why they started eating each other
when they probably didn't need to
um they checked these three guys bones
and that was not it they they didn't
have
a bunch of thank you they didn't have a
bunch of lead in their bones because
apparently they can tell
they said they had been exposed to him
like a long time ago but industrial
pollution
but from industrial pollution but they
said if it had been from the cans like
in the last like year or whatever of
their life it would have been like a lot
like spiked a lot higher and that wasn't
it so they said that probably wasn't why
so they still don't know why these
[ __ ] all ended up eating each
other
so but and but that was like that was
one of my favorite things that we saw on
this because
the mysteries of the deep they do like a
thing like
they talk about like three or four
different mysteries
like on every show like they talked
about you know that famous case about
like all those feet inside of the like
the severed feet inside of the shoes
that keep like washing up and [ __ ]
it's not nova scotia so i can't remember
where it is they didn't know why they
left the ships that had a couple years
of food in them and why they died yeah
there was three years with the food in
there
and the guys who were asking this
question and doing the investigations
are
there they're scholars and scientists
which
kind of a book wormy type people they
don't go out into real low temperature
environments for a long time
having served in korea in the infantry
and been outside [ __ ] two months at a
time at
40 degrees [ __ ] blows they're 20
degrees below zero
they don't understand the effects of
[ __ ] long-term cold
on the human mind doesn't require
anything they did kind of bring that up
on the show that they said that maybe
after a while because they were stuck
there for a long time they went and
maybe
they just all went insane because yeah
you know
they said that does something to your
mind like just looking at nothing but
ice and snow for miles and miles for
months and months and years at a time
it was a high level levels of stress
fatigue
borderline hypothermia and hypothermia
for long periods of time
even though they were prepared for it i
mean i guess like i said they were
prepared to be out for three years
yeah so and you're dealing with you're
dealing with
you know um semen
okay the kind they're right on the scene
in your trousers
they're they're they don't come from a
background of arctic
[ __ ] survival
they didn't record they didn't get any
kind of training conditioning or mental
conditioning or anything they haven't
been selected
uh through a process of [ __ ] survival
of the fittest which
which happens during like basic training
type situations when an army is really
strong
who is strong and who is weak it's just
random [ __ ]
and in extreme environments random
[ __ ] don't make it
even strong [ __ ] [ __ ] with
badass [ __ ] attitudes
and high levels of endurance eventually
they fail
it's only a matter of time okay
so you don't know about troop quality
control well the thing about
nature is that nature is gonna kick your
ass
i don't care how
you're just one tiny little
insignificant person yeah the difference
between the weak and the strong
in a situation like that would be a few
months maybe six months difference in
between
some guys will fail in a few weeks some
guys will fail in a couple months
some guys will fail in six months seven
months they will eventually all fail
the inuit weren't failing because they
had the proper equipment they had the
proper
mindset they had been selected over
generations of to survive well yeah they
had lived there for thousands of years
yes so any bad habits or bad mental
[ __ ]
dispositions and attitudes that don't
survive out in that
in the arctic all those have long since
been weeded out of their culture and
their system
all right it's gonna take special kind
of [ __ ] that can live out there
for years
and you're not gonna find that in
england or america or something not
under those
it'd be harder to find them guys that
were like that would be like jeremiah
johnson mountain man type [ __ ]
they could do it probably
but not some dude that they kind of
picked at random in some boston port you
know who
sailed been on a couple of voyages you
know in basically decent weather maybe
some storms i mean
probably real good men of the sea
under normal conditions but this is
extremes they're just
they haven't been selected for that
yeah and like i said it's very
interesting to me and they went into
this on the
um if you if you watch the because tila
was saying um
about the the tv show the terror which
is
a fictionalized account and it's based
on the dan simmons novel which is also
very good
um about this expedition so a lot of the
[ __ ] is historically accurate but then
there's like
supernatural [ __ ] going on too so it's
like you know so just know that going in
but i don't know i i kind of feel like
it was kind of sad because i the inuit
like tried to help them
they wouldn't accept help but they
wouldn't like they they were like here
we have like all the seal meat it's like
pizza meat yeah they wouldn't
that was obvious to me why they wouldn't
do it one it was raw they're not used to
eating anything raw
okay you think they'd be hungry enough
no they just and then
and then they have all this kind of
weird mentality of
like maybe they're trying to poison us
hey these people are savages we
shouldn't really be taking food from
them
for all we know that's human flesh
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ] that
might have been
but then they ended up eating each other
anyway
they're all so crazy by the time that
this happens
what can happen when you have a group of
dudes in real harsh conditions
is that the weakest ones start to
[ __ ] complain first
and the complaining and the bitching and
the whining starts to [ __ ]
demoralize all the stronger ones and
then all of a sudden they're all
bitching and whining and moaning and
then they are the morale starts to
collapse and then they start
going into like a suicidal death spiral
that's what happens
morale and mindset has a lot to do i
mean
i can't imagine and i know that they
were prepared for it like i said they
had stocked at three years worth of they
knew it was going to be a long journey
they knew they were going to be
you know stuck in the ice for a very
long time they knew that going in
yeah um they knew the conditions they
were going into and they were prepared
for it
but being prepared for it and going
through it are two different things
thank you thank you what happened was
that the ships [ __ ] got iced in
and they sat out there for what how many
months
went [ __ ] crazy well the ships were
they were stuck for 19 months i think
yeah and i guarantee you they lost track
of time
they didn't know how long they were out
there uh they also lost track of where
their location was
and then they started to [ __ ] panic
and fantasize and
somehow somebody says you know we could
walk back it's not that far
and they believed that look at the map
it's like it's not that far we'll just
walk back
and then they [ __ ] started walking
out there and [ __ ] in in just
absolute whiteness in a constant [ __ ]
world of white just snow and [ __ ] the
sky
looks kind of what i mean anytime you're
in an environment like that
yeah where we're feeling a vertigo well
it happens with people that are like
stuck out on the sea for a long time too
because everywhere you look it looks
exactly the same
there's no like distinguishing features
and i could see how that would kind of
their heads were spinning and as they
went insane they went insane
and then they started [ __ ] i'm not
following with these [ __ ]
they're going in the wrong direction and
they started
all breaking up and [ __ ] little
groups and fighting and then they all
died
yeah that's what happened and then
eventually the ship sank because they
just found them i've seen [ __ ] like this
happen in the infantry just in a single
night of [ __ ] walking around
in [ __ ] low visibility dark [ __ ]
jungle or forest where you can only see
about an arm's length in front of you
and just you get totally disoriented and
and you're like where the [ __ ]
how long is this going to take when is
it when is there going to be a break in
this
you know what i mean anything that's
kind of keeping you sane and then
rain starts pouring it's the middle of
the [ __ ] night and maybe you've been
out there for three or four weeks
you know yeah the human brain is not the
human brain is
not really um did not really evolve to
deal with those conditions
every direction you look you just see
leaves you and you're just trying to
[ __ ]
looking at him compass and trying to
look at on a map this is before gps
see y'all are [ __ ] spoiled spoiled as
[ __ ]
with his gps action we didn't have that
i can't even find [ __ ] even with gps
you're trying to [ __ ] look at
you're [ __ ] you're looking at a
[ __ ] compass going well that's north
all right and then you got a map and you
go where am i on this there aren't any
terrain features because i can only see
about three feet in every direction
am i in a valley or is this flat where
so you just [ __ ] map am i alive
because you can't do i exist
because you can't place yourself on that
map right because you can't see anything
you might as well have your eyes closed
see my god that's how i feel like every
single day even in my own house yeah so
you go like well
if that's north let's just keep going
west eventually we might hit
some water yeah
it's so that's what they were doing
imagine if there's no terrain features
well yeah that's what i mean so i think
that and i think they even brought this
up like on the show
was that there i can't remember what
it's called but there is actually a word
for a condition particularly in the
arctic
where people that have been there a long
time they said they just start like
flipping out because it's like every
direction you look it's just like
flat white yeah nothing there's nothing
and it's just kind of like so people
that are up there it just like starts
getting to you after a while and like i
said i think it gets to people that are
like on the ocean for a long time too
because
for the same reason there aren't any
there aren't any distinguishing features
everything just looks
flat and looks the same those inuits up
there
evolve for that that doesn't stress them
out in the same way that
a whale doesn't [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
about being in the
open ocean he knows what depth he's at
yeah he knows which direction he's going
he can hear whale song maybe bouncing
off something in the video
they're sending out [ __ ] whale text
messages
you know what i mean so he doesn't feel
alone and he might have a couple other
whales with him
all right and they might go in the same
direction for weeks without seeing
anything it
just doesn't stress them out well it
doesn't bother them yet yeah well that
and you like the whale yeah well their
expectations are different
and their experience is different does
this just keep going
you know yeah well like you said they
can hear others yeah also so they know
where everybody's at
and uh another thing they talked about
on that show too was that
that one guy i remember seeing this too
like two it was 2019 i think
that one guy and the baleen whale like
picked him up in his mouth
yeah like he was gonna eat him he didn't
need it he was fine
but so they were talking about why that
might have happened
because they're like baleen whales as
big and
terrifying as they are and they have
like huge mouths but it's like they
don't uh
they can't eat people they can't swallow
you um because of the way that their
mouth is constructed
so they were trying they were
speculating as to why
this one diver in particular why he had
picked him up in his mouth
and like carried him a little way i
think he probably just like
ate him by accident because he was kind
of by a big fish ball
sophie's talking about rome there she
says it sounds like more animalistic
it sounds more like animalistic behavior
they didn't have a problem with it
yeah humans still are animalistic it's
just that
to a greater or lesser degree yeah we
just like to talk ourselves out of that
the romans considered themselves to be
really evolved and very high tech and
very modern and their version of that
was basically
a hierarchy a hierarchy of people that
went up into the equestrian class and
then the patrician class
of you know knights and royalty really
that's basically what that means the
patricians were like noble families the
equestrians were like
military families of military officers
like knights
kinda then they had praetors and
senators and [ __ ]
and then they had later on praetors got
replaced with emperors and puritors
they weren't that different than us we
we like to think that we're a lot better
but
no
1800s and the 1700s was a lot like that
well the thing about it though is that i
mean i do feel like it's
better now than it was you know what i
mean well yeah
not by a lot yeah and everything's
temporary
yeah that's true everything is temporary
too everything was temporary back then
and everything is temporary now
yeah we're making this up as we go along
well yeah i mean you know we don't know
yeah we're just kind of like slightly
more intelligent monkeys
right yeah uh we're just trying to sort
the [ __ ] out give us a break
you know what i mean it's a so it's kind
of like i don't know i
i take kind of a long view because it's
like you know people like to piss and
moan about oh this is terrible and
that's terrible like nowadays
but i'm like well you know and like what
zach was saying about what time period
would you go back to
none of them because it's like as you
know as
people like to complain about how shitty
things look like this is shitty nowadays
and that's shitty nowadays i would not
go back to any
time of the past because it was way
shittier back then
it's decidedly less shitty nowadays well
now you have a much better selection of
food
you have technology that's freeing
people from drudgery
um technology that's freeing people from
government oppression
um there's a lot of things and and a lot
of the things that governments do today
are
in reaction to us becoming freer from
their control and their oppression
you see the games that they're playing
civilizations basically are always built
to serve the ruling class
and the ruling class are always kind of
pampered and
dumb they they really only worry about
themselves they don't care about anybody
else
um they only get worried about things
like uprisings and revolts
because they literally can lose their
heads during those and they have over
and over again
so it's just but the situation is
different now
if you had an uprising or revolt in one
country they can all jump on a jet and
fly away to another country
which is something they weren't able to
do back in those days
um so you just have to wait and see how
things
are gonna go uh i predict
increased freedom that's what i predict
and the ruling class won't like that
they don't make money off that
and uh i mean i got to do is look at
their reaction to the death of
television hollywood and cable tv
next the thing that's going to really
upset them is the death of the banking
system
because eventually cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin are gonna [ __ ] make them all
irrelevant and they will fight that
tooth and nail
uh i know that the state of florida i
just saw an interview with the um
mayor of uh miami and
he did an interview and they asked about
bitcoin and he said that
he wanted it so industries in
uh southern florida would accept bitcoin
and they want to be free of a banking
system uh
which i think it's a good idea it's all
it's all
um fiat currency anyway and the way the
bit
bitcoin is set up it might be less fiat
than the us dollar and if that happens
if
if if if the us if the us dollar
ceases to be the world's reserve
currency
the federal reserve bank is [ __ ] and
so is
so is the power the financial power of
the american empire that is also [ __ ]
and that might be a good idea to [ __ ]
that because
the power of the american empire has
basically been destructive in the world
in the past [ __ ]
40 50 years not good since vietnam
saying that's my opinion and i think a
lot of foreigners will back that up
we did a lot of bad [ __ ] with military
power in our banks
basically kept central and south america
[ __ ] poor
somebody was saying about uh female
general mutilation
and gramsci is making the point that you
know we find it important here
obviously uh but other cultures see it
no different than male circumcision
now that's interesting because i see i
mean obviously female general mutilation
is worse because
you know the procedure is way worse um
i'm not a fan of male circumcision
either i don't really think i don't
really think there's any reason for it
um i don't really know and particularly
in most parts of the united states i
think they do it
just uh that's kind of like the default
which i think is very weird
no it's not weird when you understand
the rationale behind it well i know what
the rationale is
i'm just saying it's weird i i just
don't really see any reason for it
that's all i'm saying it happened
because it it wasn't always real popular
in the united states but
when i was born and and sometimes a few
generations before that
most of your most of your doctors in the
united states were jewish they were
jewish americans they went to medical
school
it was in their tradition to do that and
they believed that it
prevented infections so it became oh
yeah i know so they put a
that became a um it's the default now
as far as i know i don't know or at
least a few years ago it was the default
it became a
tradition to have that kind of dawn as a
procedure
especially among white people um
there's some ups and downs in it i guess
i guess the [ __ ]
the upside of it is increased stamina
okay i don't want to talk about
okay what well i lose sensitivity so you
can go a lot i'm just gonna say that i
have a weird i think it's very
weird cutting the head of your dick off
it's right very it's very
it's very weird doing something like
that to somebody that can't consent to
it
if you want to do it later i don't have
a problem with that but it just seems
weird to like do it to a baby that just
always seemed very weird to me
well it had to do with religion too well
i know i know that yeah i'm just saying
that
it just seemed weird how it became the
default because it's like hey you want
us to cut this
like skin off your baby sure why not
yeah that just seems like a really weird
thing
i kind of have a thing about people that
because you know how for a long time
like some
people would uh like their when their uh
babies were little girls they're like
yeah pierce her ears
and i'm just like can you wait till she
gets old she doesn't really need pierced
ears she's a baby
it's like wait until she gets older and
she wants to do it you know when she's
like 12 or 13 and she wants her [ __ ]
air spears fine
but it's like why would you do something
to a baby that can't tell you hey don't
do that
that's just i don't know it seems very
weird to me that's
that's the only problem i have is a baby
can't consent to that kind of stuff
you're mutilating
a baby without asking them like what
they want
well i'm cut i don't mind it it's like
well i know but you don't know any
different
is the point that i'm making when you go
to korea
when you go to korea the girls there
will tell you that there is a difference
and there's evidence for it because you
get prolonged stamina
you can go a lot longer it's like
religious viagra
dudes that aren't [ __ ] cut evidently
in korea which was not really a thing
even though it was funny because that's
a christian country it's just it's just
not in their traditions to do it
are [ __ ] one minute wonders yeah but
i honestly i i've been with both and i
never know and i never noticed the
difference maybe that's just cultural i
don't [ __ ] know
i've never noticed a difference but i
think it's just a culture the thing is
though is equip
making making the equivalency of
a female female circumcision and male
circumcision there's no
there's well yeah and close yeah what
the point that i was making
and sewing a girl shut is [ __ ]
nothing that yeah that is
that is like a thousand times so i don't
understand so well the thing that
bothers me
is that sometimes the only reason i
brought it up was because granthar said
you know yeah they think they
don't see it any different than male
circumcision i'm saying
i think male circumcision is weird but
it's not
nearly as i don't think they should do
that either but i'm just saying that's
not nearly as bad as female general
means because
it's not just like oh we're cutting this
little ring of skin off they're cutting
your whole clitoris
off right and in some cases they're
sewing you
shut yeah that is a that is like a
thousand times worse yeah it's crazy ten
thousand times
i think it's [ __ ] crazy you're
cutting off a whole entire organ
essentially that's
like i said that's the equivalent of
cutting like a male like cutting the
head
[ __ ] up a woman's ability to [ __ ]
take a leak and well uh i
guess to take but definitely
menstruation she could die of all kinds
of [ __ ] infections and [ __ ]
well and i think a lot of them do yeah i
mean it's just a horrifying horrifying
procedure
but they also the same culture also made
eunuchs they'd take a boy cut his
dick off and bury him into [ __ ] sand
up to his neck so he couldn't [ __ ] with
it he survived then he was he could be a
eunuch
you did that goody can i be a eunuch
well they were usually captured european
boys yeah i know
during that time they were captured but
yeah it's just it's
it's a shitty like i don't know it's
just like why would you do something
why would you even think of that people
[ __ ] savages i didn't get that j
i didn't get that i don't even think of
that kind of [ __ ] and i'm like a horror
writer
i think of that [ __ ] in a fictional
context context but i would never do it
to a real person
well it depends on what period you're
talking about all right if you're
talking about the when they were doing
it in the 1500s they
did it as [ __ ] late as the 1700s
evidently they're still doing it in
certain parts
uh you know making boys into eunuchs
but it went back to [ __ ] thousands
and thousands of years when you needed
somebody to watch over the women and
he couldn't [ __ ] have a dick so you
had to do something to him you know to
make him
basically you're taking a [ __ ]
and turning him into c3po
that's what you're doing three people i
need you back there talking to the
falcon
this is somebody you can trust around
leia that's that's that's what they're
doing
even if he wanted to lay the dick on the
ladies he can't do it he can't do it and
see
and and and it would to us you're like
man that's some cruel [ __ ] well you're
dealing with a [ __ ] time where
normally they just would have killed
that [ __ ]
you know what i mean killing somebody
was not a big deal especially if it was
an enemy
well yeah they didn't really have the
concept of like every life is valuable
they didn't oh hell no they didn't
really have no life was cheap
and enemies were enemies originally were
supposed to be killed
um to to to be enslaved was like a
[ __ ]
um like a mercy that's how they saw it
you know what i killed your whole family
and your entire tribe
but i like you i'm gonna make you my
eunuch come here boy
it's gonna be like that hooray yeah
well you're dealing with [ __ ] savage
times they would have cut that kid's
head off [ __ ] normally
so you're not dealing with [ __ ]
governments either these are basically
governments as you know them you're
basically dealing with [ __ ] tribes
gangs criminal gangs by today's
standards
you know what i mean anybody who was a
badass and had a bunch of men following
him
he could call himself king and go out
and make a [ __ ] kill a bunch of
people take their
land it was kind of everybody that's how
they did it and it was kind of like the
whole the whole entire world was run by
like narco terrorists yeah
thank you thank you do you care no but
yeah it was like narco terrorists
but yeah but i know that i know that
though you can't judge them by today's
standards and they were raised that way
so it's not like you know that they were
raised in a world where they had been
going on for [ __ ] centuries
that's just how you did that's how you
did [ __ ] and it was like noble and
honorable
to do that because all the guys you
looked up to were like that
you know and all the legends that you
had were dudes like that
and there's no way to really you know
modernity is trying to erase that and
keep people from doing that
there has been some progress but like i
said it's always temporary
there were people in the greek in the
greek city-states that were trying to
stop that that didn't happen
they didn't stop it you had [ __ ] in the
roman republic where they were trying to
get rid of that and they did partially
but that was temporary
this is all gonna go away progress is
not [ __ ] linear this is gonna go away
eventually
it might take a hundred years might be
take ten years it might take a thousand
years
it might take 10 000 years it'll go away
if it well i don't know though i don't
know because we've got to a point where
and i'm not saying that like [ __ ] isn't
like you know
two steps were one step back because it
always is
but i don't know unless there's like
some
worldwide cataclysm which could happen
like i said we get like a solar flare we
can get like some
you know some [ __ ] like that um and then
people would revert yeah
but i don't world wars or something like
that but like i said i think that
i don't know i i'm not sure i think that
that we've passed like
um uh you have to think that when all
that [ __ ] was going on back then
90 of the people were illiterate yeah uh
and
poor and broke and now it's kind of like
90 percent of the world 95 percent of
the world might be more than 95 percent
of the world
are um you know are literate and uh most
people are computer savvy most people
know
technology most people know how [ __ ]
works so i don't know if it would go
exactly the same way i'm not saying that
[ __ ] wouldn't devolve into savagery
because it probably would in places
but i don't know if it would be the same
as back then i don't i just don't think
it's going to be the same
i don't think the future is pretty
predictable well no that's what i'm
saying i don't you know i'm not saying
i'm predicting it
and and actually i think trying to
predict things is pointless
because there are too many contingencies
and there's no way that anybody's going
to have to look at human behavior and
what humans are
all right and you have to look at the
past as a good
template and a predictor of the future i
don't think
technology will stop
i think technology will kind of continue
to grow
um but i don't think people will
progress very much
i predict the future will be something
kind of like at it out of frank hubert's
dune
most likely they'll have space travel
and technology
but you'll have royal families [ __ ]
you'll have
things like slaves they had them in the
in that story but they were gold what
they called
what they call them not golems
[ __ ] um golems is what they called
them
in order to get get around certain laws
that they have they would just take a
dead person
who was in good condition and revive
that person
and used a bunch of drugs and a bunch of
technology
to put a new mind inside of that
body kind of like a damn what do you
call it
um like a frankenstein but then they'd
turn that person into base
into what they called a mentat which was
kind of like
a biological version of a [ __ ] laptop
computer
and they you could buy them they were
like a slave but they were real
intelligent
real expensive and and yeah they were
like your right hand man of [ __ ]
kings and emperors and businesses
and the reason why they could do that is
because their laws did not protect the
undead
see that's some weird [ __ ] when you
think about it
they're kind of like in the way
in in blade runner you if you assembled
a person out of biological parts they
weren't a real person
and if you limited their lifespan you
could sell them as a replica or a
replicant
of a real person so as a
which was like a biological robot is
what they were making
you'll see [ __ ] like that eventually
probably happened
or human and animal hybrids where where
it's not human so you can
buy it and do this and that because it's
you know
mostly an animal it just happens to look
like a human
just gonna [ __ ] they're gonna have
some crazy [ __ ] well i think in the next
few decades we're gonna have to wade
into like some moral quagmires because
like i said you're gonna get into ai
you're going to get into genetic
engineering
you're going to get into all that stuff
but i do
think that people are aware of it i mean
we've all seen sci-fi movies
it's like people are at least aware of
the concepts and are aware it's not like
it's gonna catch people
uh off guard because everybody's already
seen movies they already kind of know
that that kind of [ __ ] is possible
you know what i'm saying so it's kind of
like you know we'll have to hash it out
when the [ __ ] actually happens
zach thank you very much zach zack says
jenny which of your own stories
do you want to see done as a movie
do you know i actually one of my short
stories that i wrote
uh i actually wrote it for a movie like
for a guy that was
gonna make a short movie of it and then
like he didn't end up doing it in the
end i don't think
um but i wrote a story called i mean
there's a bunch of what i'd like to see
in this movie
but he wrote one called uh i wrote one
called williams pond which was kind of
about
sea witches like who are these like
witches that kind of like lived under
the planet like they ate babies
and i think that would actually make a
good movie
i mean just i don't know this i'm
picturing it all of my short stories
when i write them
i picture them as movies first that's
how i write them
i picture them as a movie and then i
write down what's going on in the movie
camp guy brings up huxley and that yeah
huxley's another good one
and you kind of see you kind of see
tendencies towards what huxley was
talking about in brave new world already
happening
masses of people you can just eventually
just kind of dope them up to be quiet
and then you kind of get rid of excess
population that you don't need
you have different various levels of
people you have
like people that own everything they're
kind of like the alphas and then like
the betas
beta plus and beta minus minus people
who are
run the businesses of the alpha people
and then like the
cs and the ds they had all that [ __ ] and
then then you have like
like in like in huxley and in [ __ ]
thx 11 38 the shell dwellers where
you just genetically engineer a bunch of
people to be small and little
and efficient so you don't have to feed
them much and they're up there
fixing the city superstructure and
they're they can't even talk you know
that kind of [ __ ]
jenny's a good person and she had and
jenny's a good person so
she cut i'm not so i don't trust
[ __ ] with power
i think that i don't trust anyone either
i don't think they like us
i think we're a threat to them i
understand that i'm a good person but i
know that other people are not
yeah they're not good like i don't get
it because like right you know
but i but i get it you know what i'm
saying i don't
i don't right because i don't feel like
that but i understand that other people
yeah like look i read about serial
killers all day long i know about that
[ __ ] okay
um what rises to the top in every system
is somebody who's kind of psychopathic
that's how they become successful they
do it on the backs of other psychopaths
kind of like what you see in the roman
old roman system
and who runs the show right now they see
us as garbage
and they see us as a threat and an
obstacle to them
they would like to reduce the population
and replace us with something that is
not a threat to them
something small and a little herbivore
without
gender or sex who doesn't ask for
anything that can go in a little shell
or a pod
and leave them alone and then you die
off you know what i mean
to help the environment and carbon and
to make carbon neutral [ __ ] you ain't
[ __ ] they're trying to get rid of you
while they fly around
in jets that's what's happening and
that's like something out of huxley
they give a [ __ ] about you they're
scared of you
so they're just sitting here with their
political parties and their [ __ ] news
agencies and divide and conquer
they're going to get us to kill one
another and then they're going to
release
deadly [ __ ] viruses risky vac
experimental vaccines i think you need
your tinfoil hat
they hate us everybody needs i have that
feeling because i'm seeing it i'm gonna
give that damn tinfoil hat [ __ ]
[ __ ] where's your [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] hold on one second
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah they let bill cosby
out today
you have to close that back up because
you don't get the pretty light i'm gonna
put my
okay my like a founding [ __ ]
what's up
like a founding [ __ ] father i
knew that i'm the judge i'm passing
judgment
i think you well you look like mozart
i think you look like mother do the
laugh
do the laugh no no no
he's no thank you
[Laughter]
this is sophie sent him this was for his
birthday yeah
and he put came in my office with that
on yesterday and i didn't laugh
curling right man oh my god i got the
clothes to match this too
if you i will give you twenty dollars if
you wear that out to the club with all
of your likes and and do the laugh you
have to do the laugh
also yeah why are you no fun well first
of all this is not
mozart's mozart didn't have this wig
this is like he had one kind of like
this is like
jefferson this is this well okay if you
want to be like [ __ ]
thomas jefferson yeah this is jefferson
would have this wig
all right mozart actually
[Laughter]
mozart was actually kind of a [ __ ] bag
well no you know what okay so let me
talk
i think we talked about some of the side
tracks before but i will say
i love that movie amadeus is one of my
favorite movies of all time
okay but it's not
super historically accurate kind of
historically
mozart was kind of like that but not
that much also salieri was
not that much of a dick and he did not
kill mozart
yeah so you know that that was a play it
was a play the movie was based on the
play
it's an awesome movie the play was good
but it's not real historically actually
tell me to pull it forward
no actually it should you should have
plenty of forehead on on
on a wig like this you're getting five
head though i feel like that's fine
plenty of forehead because you need to
pull it forward a little bit there you
go
that's bad because they know they didn't
have hair
hold on that's too far yeah they didn't
have hair they [ __ ] shaved that [ __ ]
a lot of times what have you been doing
it was just [ __ ] wigs
and holy [ __ ]
see this is some [ __ ] see that's some
[ __ ]
jefferson [ __ ] man see i love it i love
jefferson i love that
yeah i love that i'm a [ __ ] founding
father
all right patriotic as [ __ ] all right
even got my spectacles on fourth of july
is coming up
but it's not ben franklin though because
ben franklin kind of
he had kind of his own hair he just had
a ponytail as he went both with his own
hair
he was just like [ __ ] i'm not doing
that wig well he said about that
um that wig wigs were for
people who were basically uh trying to
show off
you thought that was too european yes
you should you know you shouldn't wear
flashy [ __ ] clothes and don't wear a
wig
just have your own ponytail like just
take me as i am [ __ ] yeah ben
franklin very ahead of his time yeah i
gotta say
yeah he was puck rock plus he was a pony
hound phone hound
and a nudist [ __ ] sit out naked in
front of us ben franklin was kind of an
awesome dude yeah
and uh didn't they loved him in france
yeah yeah didn't believe in marriage
i mean he was just kind of he was very
very modern
he was very you could go back to the
time machine
yeah and bring him to now and he'd
probably fit right in he'd have been
stinky though i think by the days well
you could wash him for christ's sake
thank you gadgey3 late cause of pub yeah
i know how that goes happy pre-birthday
tom
half cuts that might not hang about uh
love you guys and everyone here what's
half cut you cop
it's not hanging about half half drunk
oh okay oh okay
yeah i thought it was half circumcised
and it wasn't hanging it's like wait
what it
oh it went terrible i'm not gonna get
this [ __ ] [ __ ] curled i got a car
yeah you gotta curl that
and curl that [ __ ] it's beautiful yeah i
gotta get in there with some curlers and
fix that
he's gonna put curlers in the wig yeah
you gotta curl it man my [ __ ] curls
are [ __ ] up
hold up where's the part
yeah oh my god you're killing me you're
killing me
it makes you more intelligent it makes
me look like i belong on a [ __ ] money
put me on a [ __ ] like one of the
dudes off the money
oh my god bill that should be the next
t-shirt
yeah we should do money with this a 13
13 oh [ __ ] i'm writing that down yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's
a 13 bill yeah and i'll put it on i'll
put on
the wig on it yeah i'll put on my 1700's
clothes and everything which i got
i got i got seven eighteen hundreds
clothes i'm writing that down yeah
that's a that's a [ __ ] awesome idea
oh my god thirteen dollar bill yeah
we could do like a shirt with that on it
that's right if you're on that [ __ ]
money
you got hair like this you guys [ __ ]
hatching ass nose
people gotta listen to you yeah it's the
law
you can your penmanship gets a lot
better when you put this off yeah i'd
like to see that because you're a
penmanship yeah your penmanship gets
real [ __ ] good
you start bequeathing [ __ ] to people
what am i going to get before you know
i'll
i'm not be [ __ ] make don't question
me when i [ __ ] say crazy [ __ ] cause
then you're making me invent more stuff
well i thought you liked that though
okay all right like i know i'm just
talking [ __ ]
he's just saying that because he's not
gonna be with me anymore
i'm gonna crazy um
all the bed sheets all my clothes i
bought those anyway okay all right
you didn't buy the clothes no i bought
the sheets though all right
don't make me sit don't make me change
wigs
oh [ __ ] made me change what's going to
happen if you change wigs
this is i think this might be my
favorite wig of everyone that you
yeah i mean
i know i know that you want to be thomas
jefferson or
george washington yeah yeah i thought
you would have circumcised bro when you
said that
they have different reasons i deserve my
own money bill yeah i i don't know who
said that first
i think i said it maybe i said so wig
conspiracy
the wig and the conspiracy theory are
both great okay so maybe
also you should put a tinfoil hat on top
of the wig
then you can go oh and then you can talk
about conspiracy theories about like
uh masonic [ __ ] like on the [ __ ]
dollar bills and stuff
like illuminati i don't believe in any
of that concert i know we did a show
about that a while yeah
i don't believe in any of that [ __ ]
either but no i'm just saying that it's
like
that would kind of go like go with it
thank you don the bomb happy birthday
for tomorrow
tom i've heard rumors dennis raider
wanted an invite
[Laughter]
he can show up if he can get if he can
get free
don't even say that you'll never get
free although seriously if dennis raider
his stupid dumpy old ass like showed up
at our house for a birthday party i
think i would probably just like
he called it he's just like look like
i'm landing on falco remember the
[ __ ] falco video
rock me amadeus yeah yeah yeah yeah
or the original door commissar yeah yeah
the commissar yeah
he did the original drug connoisseur
we're sandra sander probably knows falco
yeah yeah like he died right like in a
car accident
i don't know he did he did and um i had
a couple of his singles he did rock me
amadeus i think that's
what everybody knows he did the original
of der commissar
which i think in the u.s they were more
familiar with the
later version which came out in 82 which
was done by an american or a british
band called after the fire
so they did that but yeah i like the uh
after the fire version better i gotta
say but the falcon one's good too
and he did a song called genie which was
actually quite good that was sort of a
minor hit over here i had like the 45
of it t am i more caucasian with this on
did i get wider
i mean i think you did yeah i'm more
cocky
trying to figure out how the ears should
go yeah man this is me
and this is me in my full full
caucasian tribal outfit
[Laughter]
i feel like that would look so much
better with like your [ __ ] your
my jackets that jacket that you have
yeah
i mean i'm seeing i'm seeing a halloween
costume in the future
oh yeah you need to be mozart can i be
costanza
you've been saying mozart but no it's
not mozart man
mozart did not have this wig
but he had one kind of like that well
the one mozart had
it well at least in the movie it was
kind of crazy and it was kind of like
spiky and thick
because he was like mozart did not have
any curls this is
this is like jefferson but that was like
a standard wig for the time
that was the standard you look kentucky
fried white
so stila cool cool that's all he's i'm
milling in
my melon and count dropping
my my uh my status level as a white boy
started to rise see it started to go up
over
now all the other white boys are getting
jealous see he's oh man look how white
that dude is
oh my god i need to like step up my
whiteness game yeah that's a real honky
over there
hockey level um honky level 11.
11. achieved sure yeah
i really do like that wig though he came
in like wearing that i'm like that's
that's fantastic no i'm not [ __ ]
you know so okay so sophie said she sent
you
three okay i got it now we've got two of
them we haven't got the third one yet
so i've like unleashed this now i'm in
yeah we haven't
i'm not going to tell you what it is but
it's like um
this is my favorite one so far because
when he came out it's like i wouldn't
even even thought of getting that she
hasn't you haven't seen the other one
with me on it
well i haven't seen the other one on you
haven't seen it on yeah yeah because you
just got it i think it didn't beat it
ready
and that's ready i gotta get glasses to
go with it though
wait do you need glasses i feel like you
might need some other props
all kinds of [ __ ] don't spoil it i'm not
i'm i'm not i'm just saying that
i feel like you might need other props
that's all i said seeing everybody's
doing i was going to say something but
then i decided not to because that would
spoil it
tom has given his time is giving white
boys summer
i'm not sure what white boy summer is
tom you look yeah feel free give us a
tom you look yummy now in all your
whiteness
the gays are loving it
[Laughter]
well you know yeah it's gonna be wearing
pantaloons and [ __ ]
yeah you need some pantaloons you don't
have any pantaloons
no not at all hold on you had some guys
we could get this [ __ ] right man you had
some uh i
almost looked like a damn british judge
a no that's a that's like a lawyer
that's a lawyer yeah
they all wear those though yeah but
they're not they're like gray and
they're like curly but they're like all
the way down kind of they don't have
like the ponytail in the back but it's
similar
yeah it's what they call a big wig yeah
so you got a big wig then you're [ __ ]
bored
well yeah that's where they're that's
where that term came from yeah big wig
because you guys you have the biggest
wig yeah
i like that it suits you okay i'm trying
you need a bigger nose yeah i need a big
old [ __ ] hawk nose
you need a bigger hatchet face like
those [ __ ] had
yeah like they had some hats and ass
[ __ ] pieces turned sideways you're
like oh man no turn back the other way
dude
they had a big old [ __ ] bridge on
their nest yeah they did look like
they all looked like some kind of eagle
or a hawk or something
[Laughter]
well if yeah [ __ ] nose that's what
you needed that's what you needed
he's got that [ __ ] face then he must
be able to tell me what to do yes
you know yeah um how about a 17th
century wooden tooth grill
a tooth drill grill grill oh okay you
know washington with the wooden teeth
you know what i mean
yeah oh oh i heard that that really
wasn't true
well even if it's not yeah like so many
people believe it that if you dress up
oh you should dress up like george
washington for halloween
and you should put like wooden like
something that looks like wooden teeth
i heard that there would that it and you
should have an axe and a like
for and some cherries also i heard that
they i heard that the truth behind it
was is that they they had
false teeth they were metal and pewter
and they did have some wood but the
teeth the teeth part
like that well i thought they made them
out of like dead people teeth
uh i heard it was porcelain that they
dug out of graves or
that were just from like skulls that
were just laying around that sounds a
little macabre but i don't think so i
think of the porcelain
yeah but we're talking about a long time
ago and they're just like you know
whatever dead these dead
skeletons are people laying around
i don't think they put dead people's
teeth in their mouths when they could
make
porcelain they could also make things
out of ivory
yeah you know and then they could paint
things i just don't think so i'd have to
little more i don't know look at that it
would not surprise me one bit
if they're just like hey well i'm not
saying like the best ones like the rich
people they probably like personal ones
but for like the next tier down yeah
like the cheaper version
they probably just like dug like teeth
out of [ __ ] graves and stuff because
look how cheap that would be be free
because they made a lot of porcelain
dishware
and it would have been easy to cut
something and polish it
but much easier to pry people like dead
people and free like i said
just labor time that's all german says
tom can take his seat at the uk supreme
court now
sure yeah yeah i'm ready he looks like
king george
[Laughter]
he's getting too far you're gonna put
the other one on yeah brian says they
used slave teeth see that's what i
thought
it all sounds apocryphal to me i don't
know that sounds totally plausible
because like i said if you had [ __ ]
if you had a resource that was free yeah
um
i'm imagining that you would probably do
that oh this is the second wig let's see
how it looks
oh oh this one's good this one's good
you guys you guys
i haven't seen this one on yet
i was like
[Laughter]
i want to thank you all for coming to my
birthday
[Music]
[Laughter]
i want to thank you very much for coming
to my birthday online birthday party
and same thing to you grandpa's and uh
everybody else and no need for me too
i'd like to thank you very much for
coming to my birthday party today i feel
like just feel just like i'm back in
nashville
i think you need some like sunglasses
yes i was saying these are the only ones
that i have though
like you look more like kind of like roy
or
yeah with elvis hair those are my
sunglasses by the way i'm coming back
one day come what may on blue bayou
there you go there you go thank you
yeah these are my sunglasses i don't
have any big like yellow ones like elvis
had
yeah that's pretty fantastic i need the
elvis glasses
that's what i mean you need that to like
complete the look comment section is
going crazy
you could also be elvis for
halloween yeah yeah
esther says oh my well kind of always
elvis anyway
esther says oh my god tom jenny does
that wig turn you on
well not really but like you know what i
mean it's kind of it's entertaining
though
i'm entertained is it turning her on
yeah this is the first time i've seen it
yeah i think i like the mozart one
better
i'm a weirdo you know that right
german says haha rockabilly dumb uh zack
asked me a couple of times so i guess he
really wants to know the answer
what was the case that i wrote about
elvis has entered the building
right yeah the stray cats are back he
also said that
um zach asked me what case that i had
written about in faceless villain that
still stuck with me
for whatever reason a lot of the cases
that stuck with me the most
are older ones i guess because
i know that they will never be solved
and that bothers me
and we did a show about it a while back
but that whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the dude that checked into the
hotel this was like back in the 30s
that checked into the hotel and it was
acting super weird and then he turned up
dead it was like
uh horror in room 1046 i think is what
they call it
and then um they didn't know who he was
for a really long time
like he ended up like [ __ ] murdered
and [ __ ] oh my god look at you
go ahead go ahead do [ __ ] how can i do
the show with you
sitting over there looking like that
[Laughter]
see this one he's always like you just
go ahead and talk while i'm over here in
an
elvis wig and goggles
just go ahead and talk about normal [ __ ]
we'll wear this [ __ ] to the club
you should yeah honestly you should do
i think you should do the mozart wig
though but like you should wear all the
clubs
now that i've seen that with the uh
the thomas jefferson slash mozart wig on
you and also the elvis one
i kind of want one of those fabulous
wigs
like they showed in amadeus that the
ladies had
that were like that but were like really
big and had like [ __ ] ships and swans
yeah i want one of those and i want the
whole [ __ ] outfit man i want like the
[ __ ]
corset like the big huge [ __ ] gown
you kind of have one though
i have one like that yeah i do have one
like that but it doesn't have like the
big
the hoop yeah i need the hoop sophie
said she watched elvis and nixon this
weekend that's a good movie
did you like it i liked it yeah i liked
that movie too yeah
there's another movie called frost nixon
which was also really good which was
kind of
like about it was an interview that he
did
with a uh british journalist i saw it in
the theater
i feel like so it was like a lego tina
said that jenny was thrown off by tom's
sexiness
but with it yeah so he's like looking at
me like is that true yeah yeah
so sexy with this [ __ ] win no that's
not true it's just very
you're ridiculous miss is very
distracted
here i'll make this another drink let me
make us another drink hold on baby
okay
i was just gonna well no bananas though
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind with peanut
butter and jelly and bacon on it
i'll just make it called fool's gold
yeah see
so that's good yeah that would be good
i'm gonna eat a whole loaf of bread with
a [ __ ] peanut butter jelly
bacon on it no bananas though [ __ ] that
i mean i should be marie antoinette i
thought about it one year
we did he was kind of well he dressed in
something i said
he looked like jack the ripper and i was
dressed like
who was the jack the ripper victim that
had all of her uh
that had all of her intestines hanging
out i know there was more than one
i was that i was her so i dressed up as
like as a victorian hooker but i also
had like a bunch of intestines that he
had on my stomach so
i'm so classy but yeah so that's what i
did one year so we were jack the ripper
and jack the ripper victim
we don't usually do couple costumes
though because he won't
i always kind of wanted to um you know i
do bride of frankenstein and he's like
[ __ ] it i'm not dressing up so it's like
you know i'm single bride of
frankenstein but it's that kind of thing
one okay so there are actually two
aspirational halloween costumes i've
always wanted to do
one i always wanted to do
kali i was going to be kali uh you know
the indian goddess of
creation and destruction uh with all the
arms
but if i like i thought about doing it
one year and i was just like man this is
gonna be too cost prohibitive
because if you're gonna do it it has to
look cool
and then a year or two after i decided i
couldn't afford to do it
that [ __ ] [ __ ] uh heidi klum
the model that was on the show she
uh she did it and it looked amazing and
i was like okay well i can't do it now
because obviously
hers is like superior because she has
all the money
thank you there you go cilla
[Laughter]
i'm not that much younger than you
though hold on one second
and another one that i wanted to do if
you guys have seen the 2001 movie
dagon based on well based on the hp
lovecraft story but it's not really
based on the hp lovecraft story dagon
it's based on the hp
lovecraft story uh shadow over anne's
mouth
there is a woman in that who plays
like kind of a priestess of the fish
cult
people and she has this fantastic
like gold she's in a wheelchair uh
because she has
tentacles instead of legs and also she
has like this fantastic like gold outfit
and she has like this gold crown that's
like super cool
and i wanted to do that one year too but
again a little cost prohibitive
because i feel like if you're gonna do a
halloween costume
one i don't want i want it to be like
super as accurate as possible which
costs a lot of money
two i don't really care if anybody knows
exactly what it is
but i want it to be accurate enough that
dorks who know what it is
like i'm a dork who knows what it is
will be like oh my god
you dressed up as that you're the most
awesome person ever that's
you know that's kind of my angle so
those are my two aspirational
also i want to do um what's-her-face
from uh
flash gordon but again i looked into
doing that one year because we were
going to be
he was going to be uh god damn it
emperor clitus or whatever and i was
gonna be like what's her face
kala kala now we wanted to do the whole
outfits with like the
she has this crown that's made of like
this
[ __ ] i don't even know what it is it's
kind of like these kind of plastic beads
sort of but they were kind of like
opalescent
and she had this whole like uh crown
this whole headpiece that was made out
of it and kind of like a neck piece that
was made out of it
and i was like i looked into the cost of
doing it because we were gonna do it for
um
for a convention one year and i was like
i was like this is gonna cost
a thousand dollars like to do it exactly
like
in the movie because like i said if
you're not gonna do it exactly like the
movie i don't really see the point of it
and so i abandoned the idea that year
but i still want to do it one of these
days when i have money
uh no need for me too thank you very
much love the dagon actress here's to
half sister tentacle love
i said i still want to do that i think
that would be like the best [ __ ]
wouldn't that be a [ __ ] awesome
halloween costume for me to do i have no
idea that chick from dagon
oh yeah yeah i've been wanting to do
that for you the wheelchair though
i need a wheelchair i need tentacles
i mean getting the wheelchair in the
tentacles that probably the easiest part
i feel like making the crown would
probably the hardest part
maybe i could buy it on etsy yeah they
said people live long in my family
what's she dumbo
she's talking to somebody else oh uh
jenny have you seen equilibrium
with christian bale i don't think i have
actually okay
i don't think i have actually say what
acidified scene equilibrium with
christian bale everybody's telling us to
watch it sounds really good
okay i'm going to write that down
because yeah i don't think i've seen it
it doesn't sound super familiar
i can't do the t saw dagon dagon's are
[ __ ] good when i got that [ __ ] on
blu-ray
i love that movie jenny got that for
music gift it's like a special release
blu-ray
i mean i feel like honestly
there there haven't been a lot of great
lovecraft adaptations there have been a
lot of great lovecraft inspired movies
but there haven't been a lot of great
movies that have been
based directly on lovecraft's
[ __ ] um other than the like the
lovecraft appreciation society they make
kind of like short films
and a lot of them are kind of like in
black and white and they're all kind of
they made like call of cthulhu and they
made like some other ones and those are
really cool
i think you can watch them on youtube i
think on youtube or like you can buy
them off their website
those are good but honestly
i'm gonna say of all the direct
adaptations
i think dagon was like the closest to
the story even though it wasn't
actually an adaptation of dagon it was
an adaptation of shadow over intimate
but it was still adapted from a
lovecraft story and i think it really
captured
the wet fishy just
kind of like i don't know it it just
gave me a really love crafty and feel to
it
and it's a pr it's pretty close to the
story i think yeah it's funny because a
lot of people could
criticize the hell out of it for not
being very good but second i don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
i saw somebody else review it and they
said i loved dagon i saw somebody else
review it on youtube recently
they said that in the title of the
review is the best horror movie you
never saw
and you're like yeah i beg to differ i
have seen it yeah but i think yeah
several times i think the average people
haven't seen that one
it's a good idea yeah it came out what
2001 i think 2001. yeah it had a shitty
release
it just kind of released like well it
was just kind of like a half-assed
like wet fart of a relationship that
happened
and it was because of the company and it
was evidently it got a good release in
spain where they made it
well they made it there but it didn't
get a good release in the united states
and it just kind of
oozed out into [ __ ] on dvd
like a test like a [ __ ] ejaculation
and nobody noticed it except people who
were
into into like from beyond and jeffrey
calls movies than
in the lovecraft type stuff i think they
knew but
nobody else really knew about it i mean
i don't know the thing is it's like and
we're still waiting for gamora el toro
to make
at the mountains of mexico i mean
they've been talking about that since
2009.
i don't i feel like that's like his
passion project
we're still waiting for them to release
the new dune i don't think they'll ever
will release that [ __ ] movie
because the bomb says not seen dagon but
heard stuart gordon directed it yeah he
did
um it was uh i really liked it you know
what i mean it's
i hesitate uh to recommend it just
because some people are like oh it
sucked your blah blah but i loved it i
thought it was like
fantastic i thought it was very
lovecraftian one of the most
uh accurate adaptations i've act of
lovecraft's stuff that i've actually
ever seen
i could recommend it if you know
anything about lovecraft yeah
like lovecraft if you liked from beyond
if you liked um
uh herbert west reanimator if you liked
um
uh what was the one um what was that one
movie that had lovecraft in it oh that's
right
that's awesome economically i even liked
that one we have that one on the
dvd or blue air no we don't don't we
don't no
we uh i thought somebody sent us that i
don't think so
i thought we just watched it recently we
watched it recently
it was i think it's in public domain
i think we saw that that happens i think
so i think it's on youtube
man i go back and look at i don't think
we have it you know it's okay so i don't
really know how
copyright law works maybe if somebody's
like a copyright lawyer they can tell me
one movie that i reviewed the review is
coming out on saturday or friday if
you're a patron
and it was a movie called dominique or
dominique is dead if you're in the uk
and i remember seeing it on cable when i
was a kid and being like oh that was
super creepy or whatever it's a very
standard like kind of ghost story
like dude is gaslighting his wife and
kills her and blah blah
it's that kind of or she kills herself
you'll see
and so uh what ended up happening with
that
it was made in 1977 in the uk i think
even though most of the actors were
american
and then it went into public domain
somehow
so now any [ __ ] that wants to
can upload it to youtube
i watched it on to be but apparently
there's not any
copyright restriction i guess it was a
similar thing that happened tonight a
living dead because the same thing
happened night of living dead which came
out in 1968 obviously
and i guess he didn't like really file
the paperwork right
and they're like okay well it's public
domain now so you can't like make any
money off it
i'm not really entirely sure how that
works i mean i always thought
david june can't get the [ __ ] show to
load for some reason
go out and come back in man
no need for me too says on hbo cast a
deadly spell
another lovecraft uh adaptation hidden
gem oh thanks victor
thank you victor thank you very much
happy birthday eve i'd like to thank you
very much for uh sending me a birthday
present thank you very much
if you're having problems with the show
go ahead and go out and come back in
restart your computer
okay so if you do an elvis costume for
something for halloween or whatever
do the glasses uh get a leisure suit
with as much [ __ ] bling on it as you
can imagine
and then in your hand you should have
a peanut butter nana sandwich i wouldn't
get a leisure suit man i'd [ __ ]
uh do do his damn um one-piece jumpsuit
that's right well yeah doesn't remember
the once-piece jumpsuit almost like
something that [ __ ]
evil knievel wore evil knievel was
copying elvis
but i do that with a collar [ __ ] with
[ __ ]
eagle and sequences [ __ ] over the front
of american eagle and
yeah elvis you know like i think you
should wear that to mannequins just
because
it doesn't have to be halloween or
anything or you know a lot of people
don't realize that
some of elvis's clothes that he wore
when he was not on stage
um he just wore when he made an
appearance or just running around in
public
had a very proto-goth look to it he wore
a lot of black velvet he had a very
vampire
very vampiric look to him when he wasn't
on stage
he was uh i think a little bit
proto-goth
yeah and so were a couple of other
people from that time period you know
melanie
and better known as the vampire olsen
knows vampire um
somebody's there have been some
some people saying that elvis really
liked vampire movies hammer horror
movies and
so how can you not though yeah and
hammer horror movies are awesome and if
you looked at
scilla a lot of stuff that was
kind of looked like something out of a
hammer horror film her hair and stuff
kind of 60s and 70s it was kind of goth
looking
so i think elvis would have liked goth i
think he kind of was
proto goth in his final phases
before his um his his weight became a
problem
you know and i know uh sophie just
saw the movie and [ __ ] t's going like
i'm gonna see elvis elvis and uh and
nixon
elvis and nixon's great movie got it on
blu-ray i love that movie
now there's michael shannon's in it and
shannon is red and everything
yeah and he doesn't look like elvis but
he pulls it off yeah he acts like elvis
in it
well he's like channeling the spirit of
it yeah i mean he's not doing an elvis
impersonation
and and you know he he talked to elvis's
friends who are still alive and they're
like yeah he was like that you know
thank you david june happy birthday ross
t baggins he said thank you thank you
but uh he was uh
yeah elvis was kind of interesting i
mean
i kind of have a theory about what
happened to him um
also thank you phil thank you very much
graham thank you very much
happy birthday daddy tom thank you very
much
i'll see you graceland tila said hi my
hubby just walked in and said is that
fonzie
no so presley
hit the jukebox it was aaron presley
tupelo mississippi
transplanted to nashville but uh
i think what happened to him you know he
was that i don't know thank you very
much
thank you very much for appearing today
i don't know it's just the the
outlandishness of the situation it was
just
like hitting me at once i guess victor
said we still need to watch take shelter
i know it's like every time i like
go into like netflix or amazon prime it
comes up and i'm just like goddammit i
still need to watch that
i will watch it but um
in his final decade he didn't really
look like something from the 50s
you know the the old elvis was gone
and he uh he looked like almost
futuristic 70s
really and he kind of had a kind of a
like i said kind of a little bit of a
vampiric [ __ ] thing going and i think
i think it's true what they said is that
he really liked hammer horror movies
because he was wearing a lot of dark
velvet black velvet stuff
kind of like a vampire so so did cilla
i can show you pictures i can show you
guys pictures if you want to i could i
can pull him up
exactly what he ended up looking like
he was interesting um
i think i think he hit andrenopods early
and [ __ ] [ __ ] him up he got fat
he thought he was sick and started
taking a bunch of drugs the drugs
helped to [ __ ] his adrenopause to
[ __ ] kick in early he they didn't
know what it was back then
[ __ ] needed trt he'd [ __ ]
been all right that
but uh maybe i don't know i think that's
what it was no there's been all kinds of
now
i saw all kinds of pro i saw all kinds
of programs
they were trying to hypothesize that he
had a medical problem which he said he
did
he was saying he's constant pain but he
was addicted to [ __ ]
painkillers they kept giving him they
kind of did to him what they did to
[ __ ] prince
and and uh
here's all the drugs you want they did
it to prince and [ __ ] um
uh michael jackson you can find a doctor
that'll give you any drugs you ask for
well if you got money if you got money
you pretty much find anything you want
so his doctor kind of killed him i'm in
no danger right
now i've seen some programs that try to
that try to rationalize what happens and
well he had fibromyalgia
no no it was drug addiction
and the drug addiction [ __ ] makes
your uh
uh causes uh testosterone production to
[ __ ]
crash especially in a guy his age
who's lived on a high as long as he did
and he was not a dude that was built to
age and he started to age a little bit
and he went into a [ __ ] spiral of
[ __ ] low t and drug abuse
drug addiction and uh he died um
had you got him off them drugs and
[ __ ] juiced him up was [ __ ]
good [ __ ] test he would have [ __ ]
made it he'd made a comeback
he was not old he was 41. he was young
i mean he was fairly young when he died
41 42 i think your problem too and this
kind of arises a lot with people that
are famous
or they get really famous when they're
young is that
everybody knows you at that age it's
like that look and everything like that
and you start getting old like everyone
does
and they can't handle it as well as just
some normal ass [ __ ]
can because your whole identity was
based
it is based around you being young and
beautiful and being in all this stuff
and then when you don't have that
anymore
your identity you go into this like kind
of tailspin right
um which like i said maybe normal people
don't have because they didn't have
the entire world looking at them and
knowing them this particular way
right so it's kind of like in a way
that's i feel kind of bad for
somebody that got super famous yeah
looking a certain way because when you
don't look like that anymore
as you inevitably will not look like
that forever
and the state of medical technology
wasn't right and
and there was no internet to disseminate
information
um they could not synthesize
testosterone they didn't know much about
the male [ __ ] um endocrine system
they knew a little bit about menopause
they didn't know anything about
male menopause it was andrenopause
and uh drugs and alcohol will kick that
in early in a man same
in a woman too um jeans have something
to do with it also
but he was at the age where andrea pause
hits you and he he
and it really starts at around 35 slowly
you just don't notice it
and um if had he hooked up with
jacqueline lane
jacqueline could have helped him because
jacqueline was uh
started to take [ __ ] like [ __ ] like
deca and anavar
which would have substituted for trt and
he would have built right back up
because and he would have [ __ ] had it
come back to her
and and uh he'd felt a lot better um
he was specifically guys like elvis and
certain special operations combat
veterans and [ __ ] like that
are very prone to real
bad adrenopause it's just and it the the
everybody knows this now in the veteran
community and you know
elvis was also a veteran well like i
said it's it's if you
uh did a lot of [ __ ] when you were young
like you were not
young and beautiful and you're famous or
you know like you did a lot of [ __ ] when
you were a lot young like you were like
[ __ ] i don't know like a mountain
climber you were like in the military or
whatever
and it's just kind of like you kind of
like base your whole identity around
that so when you don't have that anymore
um it takes a bigger toll on you than it
would on
somebody that wasn't it you know because
it's just like it's two extremes
right if you're more like along the
middle
line
sure and uh one affects the other and
then
then the other one affects so
you come off the high depression kicks
in testosterone
production declines which leads to
depression the depression causes [ __ ]
a bigger depression and less
testosterone goes to alcohol and drugs
to try to get a high off of that yeah
but that is
suppressive to testosterone the problem
gets even worse
you got to stay high to feel kind of
normal
and your body's falling apart because
you're not getting [ __ ]
the the androgens you need to keep body
composition
body composition fat starts piling on
you get weaker uh you start going
impotent [ __ ]
and then with dude like elvis who
virility was his main
thing when that's gone then oh man his
whole identity he's going into a spiral
that killed him but they just didn't
know back then they didn't have the the
science
see this is kind of why i'm glad what
that i didn't do
like i've always been like kind of chill
and like
in the middle area no big emotional
highs no big emotional lows
just kind of keeping on keeping on in
the middle no
so it doesn't seem like a big transition
yeah i'm getting old but it's not like
it's not like i was like famous for
being like young and beautiful or
anything like that
and it's just kind of like it's much
easier it's a much easier transition it
doesn't really
seem like that big of a deal yeah i
don't like i know i'm old but i don't
really seem like that old of a person
she's aging actually very well i mean
most women don't have not aged as well
as she has at her age
um but we all age i mean i don't think
of it really
i just think about like i still feel
like yeah i'm tired and [ __ ] like that
but i don't feel like i'm almost 50
years old i don't feel like that
yeah well we're doing what we can do
because my attitudes are not one of a
an older person and that's something
that
i remember thinking about when i was a
teenager well another thing is
is that you have to understand jenny is
that you are not in a career low
you're actually in a career high your
career is still growing
you're on you're in career growth mode
well i'm still doing things that i
that i like doing that i want to do most
people
your age are in career collapsing
time okay but you don't have a normal
job
yeah so you know i mean most people are
retiring i'm really glad
and their their better days are behind
them so you don't you're not putting up
with the same
emotional battles that certain people i
mean to be honest even if i
retired which let's be honest i'm never
gonna be able to do
nobody retires anymore even if i retired
um
i wouldn't retire like i'm just gonna
lay around and do nothing you're gonna
continue to write i would retire
and instead it's like oh now i can write
that fiction book i always wanted to
write that i didn't have time to do or
[ __ ] like that like there's a million
projects you'd retire the way stephen
king retired but for sure that's the
worst yeah
well that's why as soon as stephen king
said i'm gonna retire i'm not gonna
write him i'm like shut up man no you're
not
dude kept [ __ ] coming back oh i got a
new book yeah
i knew he was going to do that you know
as i said that's what i would have done
that's what i would have done well your
job is not dependent on physicality
so it's all mental
so you're not susceptible to the [ __ ]
clock the way
you know i mean say somebody who was a
physical performer an entertainer was
like elvis yeah you know he was he
thought he was leaving that window
and what was funny is that in the 70s
at 40 you were a has-been well yeah
you were because they just well because
look at 40 45 year old
actors singers back then you were over
the hill you're over the hill
because you looked like an old person
right and nowadays because the knowledge
and the technology you look at a 40 year
old female actress in hollywood
she's [ __ ] smoking yeah smoking hot
that was not possible in the 70s not for
most women
but it was it's just that they didn't
know yeah they didn't it's
totally different yeah they're totally
different there were some people like
jack o'lantern
if you take small therapeutic doses of
steroids you'll stay younger for the
next 15 years 20 years you'll do
but he was an outlier he was an outlier
he knew he was just just him and a
couple other bodybuilders knew
that anabolics could keep now that's
like a mainstream
now it's mainstream idea sure and those
dudes that were doing that
like lelane
they couldn't believe it was happening
they were doing it just day by day
and looking in the mirror and looking at
their performance and going you know
it's been 15 years and i still look
pretty good it's weird
you know i mean they didn't know they
weren't sure they were just doing what
they normally did
take steroids yeah and if you take the
right amount
at the right time in your place where
you don't overdo it
anabolic steroids can kind of act like
testosterone replacement therapy
it's a similar situation it's not
exact but close enough that you can fake
it
yeah i'd rather have test you know
test it because that's what belongs in
there like putting false teeth in
you know thing is weird about test is
that's one-to-one anabolic
it's a one-to-one ratio between anabolic
and
um what do you call it androgenic
that's the normal some of these some of
the stuff like he was taking was like
anavar it's one to three
uh so it's three times as anabolic but
only the same amount of androgenic
and the androgenic stuff over time can
[ __ ] up like hair loss and things you
know
and secondary sex characteristics
a little bit so in a way some of those
anabolics are actually a little easier
on you than test but test is what's
supposed to be in there
so i think you kind of it's safer to air
on the side of what nature gave you
i think i have to look more into it well
yeah that's probably a safer
because that's what it was supposed to
be in there right
uh yeah so we're so i was talking about
stephen king like i said
he announced his retirement what was
that [ __ ] 15 years it was a long time
ago
because i remember hearing him say that
and i'm like even at the time
i was like [ __ ] you you're not retiring
because at that point i had read
all of his books i had brought all of
his nonfiction
i knew what his um
writing routine was that [ __ ] writes
he's like i write at least 10 pages
every single day weekends holidays
everything
i get up i write 10 pages i will not
leave until i write at least 10 pages
that's why all his books are like
[ __ ] door stops
and i respect that um because he has a
compulsion
just like i have a compulsion so i get
it
so when he said he was going to retire i
immediately knew
no you are not and he didn't i was like
you're not going to you can't
i was like because i i feel like i kind
of have the same mindset as that and
it's like i can never retire
you can never retire because you don't
because he enjoys it
i mean it's a compulsion i i don't know
if enjoy is the right word
it's a compulsion you have to so he's
never going to stop
now one thing i wanted to say somebody
was asking about stephen king
so i was in a little second-hand
bookstore
in st augustine because when i was there
i was wandering around looking for a
restaurant
and i was like oh my god look there's a
little secondhand bookstore i'm gonna go
in there
because you know i'm me so i go in there
and i'm like poking around and like the
lady that worked there was like really
awesome and
she was uh i bought a bunch of books
obviously because i needed some [ __ ] to
read for my show and i was just like
you can never have too many books um
this is not even
all the ones in the background i have a
[ __ ] ton back there but
there's a bunch up in the attic too so
and there's a bunch in that closet too
so you know
you guys don't even know so i bought a
bunch of books there
and she was all excited because i bought
one by richard layman and she was like
oh my god how many people know that he's
like old school horror and i'm like yeah
i'm all into that so we talked about a
long time
but one of the books that i bought was a
hardback
by stephen king and it was called
revival
and i had never even [ __ ] heard of it
that's how [ __ ] many books
this [ __ ] writes and i am so behind
i had never heard of this book i bought
it it's right back there i'm going to
review it but
i haven't read it yet but i'm going to
review it one of these days and i was
just because i picked it up and like
when the
when the [ __ ] did this [ __ ] write this
it only takes one book for a
[ __ ] to lose interest [ __ ]
tommy knockers came out and i was like
man i think i'm kind of done with king
it's just it depends on the person i
mean
i've done a thing where i mean stephen
king
he has been with me since i was
a child so
i'm repetitive well i lost track of him
for a while like i said the
the most recent one i had read of his
was under the dome which i liked but it
wasn't like super memorable
all of the stuff that i've read of his
that was my favorite was from his kind
of heyday like the shining and pet
cemetery are probably my favorites like
i liked all of them
christine was also really good but
after under the dome which i don't even
remember what year that was
i read that when it came out when it
first came out because i got it from the
library
and then after that i was kind of like
okay that was good but then like i
didn't
i feel like he writes like a book or two
a year and i can't keep up
because there's a bunch of other authors
that i'm into
and i can't you know i'm just one person
so i can't read like everybody's [ __ ]
so you know so i lost track so the fact
that i found this [ __ ] hardback and
it was up on top of the shelf on the
little stand or whatever
and i was like [ __ ] stephen king wrote
this big [ __ ] 500 page novel
and i had never heard of it i'm like
okay well it was only like five dollars
so i was like okay i'm gonna buy it
but i haven't read it yet but we'll see
it sounded good like when i read the
[ __ ]
thing but i don't know i have so many
books i have to read i feel like i will
never live long enough
to read all the books that i want to
read i have a big pile over there
that i still got i mean all the books
that you see behind you
there's like two shelves hold books
there's a bunch of books in there
there's a bunch of books in the attic
all of those i've read but
i have a big pile over there that i
haven't read and that's the ones that
i'm going to reveal
and i don't know and there's so many
more that i have to read
because i watch a lot of other like book
reviewer like horror book reviewers
that are like oh you got to read this
you got to read that i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i keep putting [ __ ] on my list
and i'm just never going to live long
enough it's just like i'm not never
going to live long enough to watch all
the horror movies i want to watch
not even like not even to mention all
the other genres of movies
because there's a bunch of other genres
i want to see too but horror movies are
kind of the priority
and i'm just never going to live long
enough to watch all of them which is
kind of a bummer
but you know i try you've seen all the
horror movies we talked about i haven't
seen all of them though
i was watching this video the other day
okay so there's this girl
she's super cute she's a little skinny
redheaded girl
she has a channel called spooky
astronauts and she
um is all about horror not as into gore
as me but you know she's still pretty
cool
um and she did a she did a show
the other day that i watched that was
like the 35 best horror movies on
netflix
and she was like where she's
recommending stuff so i was like i want
to watch this because i want to see how
many of these i've watched
i was happy because i had watched 80
of them i'd already seen but there were
still
20 of them that i hadn't seen so i had
to write all those down
every single time i watch a video horror
books horror movies
i'm like oh [ __ ] and then i write it
down on the list i haven't i haven't
seen that one
gotta write that down so i have this is
why i have like a huge list of like
books and movies that i still
this is why it's like kind of depressing
because i feel like i'm never gonna like
get through all the [ __ ]
and i'm never going to get all the [ __ ]
that i want to write as well
you know what i mean your head got too
hot it got too hot
i don't know maybe i have a long time
left maybe i have a long time left you
got a long time left
you're just crying you got to be here
for another 30 40 years but
maybe you're like the kind of person who
lived at 90.
just out of spite yeah well technology
is [ __ ] increasing
and technology will spite helps too
technology will
continue to increase as long as there's
corporations
and corporations aren't going anywhere
they've been around for centuries
uh so no and and they also move
technology forward
so no there's going to be and
no matter what happens to the nation
state tech corporations and
transnational corporations will continue
and that will always uh keep this [ __ ]
moving forward
especially technologically socially
legally
in terms of the nation state those
corporations don't give a [ __ ] that's
why i was saying
the future will probably be more like
something like dune but there'll still
be technology
well yeah there'll still be technology
yeah there is no real
example in history of technology ever
going backwards
even the collapse well that's why i'm
not gonna go backwards that's why i'm
not
like i'm not like pessimistic about it
because it's like [ __ ] might be bad for
a little while but it's like
the technology has gotten continued it's
gotten to such a point that i don't
think we're going to go back
it'll never go backwards no um i mean
like
when ron collapsed [ __ ] like plumbing
vanished
but that was just because that was just
one of the infrastructure parts of rome
all right and it wasn't that vital to
life
well maybe it was to some people because
it didn't have fresh water and they did
die but
the mass of humanity moved forward
weapons technology medical technology
considered
continued to kind of move forward even
through what they called the dark ages
there was still a bunch of progress
technologically
uh maybe not so much in terms of like
literature and science and
we're not saying that science of
literature and [ __ ]
what do you call it poetry and [ __ ] like
that in
philosophy it kind of went backwards but
it came back
it took centuries well that's what i'm
saying but it'll bounce back
but there wasn't a there wasn't an
internet event so
and everybody wasn't literate like that
makes a massive
difference right a massive difference
right so when literacy is stuck
it ain't going when 90 of your world
population is illiterate
there's nothing you can do uh that's a
big difference to nowadays when 90 95
of the world's population is literate
and that's a new thing
illiteracy even the united states in the
1700s 1800s most people were illiterate
that's another thing that a lot of
people [ __ ] don't realize
it wasn't until the 90s if you can read
you can figure [ __ ] out right
because somebody else wrote about that
[ __ ] it wasn't until the night early
nineteen hundreds that you had mass
literacy so i think that [ __ ]
are dumb honestly it seems dumb but it's
like literacy changes the whole game
right like i said if you can read you
can read someone else's account of how
to do [ __ ] and figure out how to do [ __ ]
yeah so and reading was something only
you know in the 17 1800s that was only
real educated people
they wanted to actually kind of keep
that a secret that was like that was
that was the old
way of saying like writing code and
being able to read computer code that
was it was equivalent
nobody knows how like this they don't
have these books only you can read this
book this is for us
that kind of [ __ ] yeah it was the same
as like reading and writing music
and we don't really have that anymore
well and like i said one ninety percent
of people 90 and 95 percent of the
people
were a little literate but also a [ __ ]
ton of people know how to
code also um
now they do so i i don't really think
there's any
equivalent and i don't think you can go
back to that time because
you're not going to lose all that
knowledge it's in everyone's brains so
yeah and then there's certain things
about machines that are [ __ ]
kind of evident when you see old
mechanical machines
even if you were in this we're in a
situation kind of like you see in mad
max fury road where people
are illiterate they don't really know
much about the past
they could see a machine an engine a car
engine and figure out how that would
work
and that's what would happen if you were
to wipe out
mankind were only a few thousand people
left there'd be a bunch of machinery
sitting around that they would easily be
able to figure out
yeah and then they would be able to
replicate that later in future
generations when there was a big enough
population yeah of course
so and then there's they can read books
even if
they lost the internet there's all these
books laying around
that's what i mean it's like even if i
don't know how to like build an engine
if i could find a book
about how to build an engine right i
will figure out how to build it
just copying an engine and then
understanding how [ __ ] internal
combustion worked
they would figure it out because there'd
be stuff laying around because how the
hell do you think i learned how to do
everything by reading about it yeah so
it's not
it what can go backwards is uh the
mentalities
and like uh ideology
can change and go backwards but
everything is in motion it would come
back
everything is kind of it's like cyclical
well yeah it's a cycle
that's why i don't worry about it too
much right just pepper asked me
what's the next thing you want to write
about so the two projects i have
on the horizon i'm doing a fourth volume
of faceless villain which is gonna be
unsolved murders
from 2000 to 2020.
and also we'll have murders that i wrote
about in my old books
or that happened in the 20th century
that were solved in the 21st century so
that's going to be a big thing
i also thought about doing like a
special edition hardback
like of all the faceless villains like
800 pages like with the timeline and
stuff
i don't know i might get to that someday
and this next faceless villain actually
sophie did
some of the research she did actually
i'm still only like two
like chapters in because i had like a
bunch of other [ __ ]
i'm gonna get back to it in a bit i have
a couple of other projects i gotta
finish but then i'm gonna get back into
that
after i do that i've been i've been
throwing around this idea for a long
time
i'm really into the idea of multimedia
stuff i'm really
into arg type stuff
i really want to do a novel
but that is like multimedia that's
almost kind of like
an alternate reality game so
i'm throwing around some ideas for that
i've got like [ __ ] pages and pages of
notes
of something that i'm like thinking
about doing
but that's kind of like i don't know
that might be a year or two down the
line
but that's something that i've been
thinking about doing i mean
i've so again this is another thing i
have a million books i want to read a
million movies i want to see i have a
million stories on the right that i'm
never gonna have time to read
i have so many [ __ ] notes of story
that i write
every time i think of something i just
like write it down somewhere
i like this [ __ ] file on my back and
i have all these [ __ ] story ideas hey
let's do this that and the other thing
you know do i think they'll ever have
time to do them so i came in and said
yeah i'm way
behind on that research sorry don't
worry about it i haven't even like
i haven't even like got to i have a
couple
um i have a couple games i gotta finish
but they're almost done
like a week or two or they should be
done and then i'm going to get back into
doing
basic film why is uh you're
oh okay because you're not in the same
part because i scrolled back
okay so i could read somebody's stuff
because i know they like made a [ __ ]
all right i gotta go to the bathroom
i'll go ahead
i'm gonna mess up your towel here
oh my god it's still light up yeah it's
still light up
seven it's actually early enough we
could go to the club if you want
yeah it's still [ __ ] light out there
right now it's hard to believe
seems like we've been doing the show for
hours i don't know how long how long the
show's been going for it's probably
maybe two hours
but it's going it's going by yeah t uh
you're you're gonna like you're gonna
like [ __ ] elvis and nixon
all right and if you if if any of you
guys have never seen elvis and nixon
go check that [ __ ] out it's on um it's
on
amazon or amazon prime
it what didn't it wasn't much i think i
only paid 299 to see it
it's just a it's just a good movie and
it's based upon
something that really happened crazy ass
elvis trying to [ __ ] meet nixon
so he could become under a an undercover
[ __ ] agent
and it wasn't a joke i don't think i
think he really did want to become
recovery
now some people said did he just want a
badge
because he collected badges and
there's a chance that he just wanted
that badge and that he was bullshitting
the president
because that's the way [ __ ] ellis was
i mean a president was just a president
elvis was a [ __ ] keg he believed
himself to be a [ __ ] king he could do
anymore
that's [ __ ] awesome man it's [ __ ]
funny but
uh he's like uh
[Laughter]
he's [ __ ] smacking the hands the
[ __ ] nixon from doing the claws and
[ __ ] trying to teach nixon how to do
[ __ ] karate it's like a funny
funny movie man i liked it cool he's
sleeping up in the tree
yeah you know we started early when
[ __ ] pookie hasn't woken up trying to
[ __ ] disturb the show
yeah she's going to just throw the door
open what are you guys doing
well it's still it's still light out
yeah i'm very happy that
i mean i don't like that she got freaked
out by the dog that time when i was gone
but since that happened she really has
uh
lost her enthusiasm for going out on the
porch no t
it's not raining but it's hot out i
guarantee you it's hot out there
yeah in florida the rain does not cool
it off it makes it worse
it's like it's like throwing um water on
the stones in the sauna
it's just gonna evaporate off the dam
off the fl off the ground and it's just
going to be
going to be steam it's hot honestly
i go for my you know hike in the morning
yeah
and i try to go early like 7 00 am
even then i come back and i'm like super
super sweaty
yeah you know what i mean it's just
really not
it's just like a thick it's not terrible
at 7am but
it's not the hottest part of the summer
either it's only the end of june
july and august are the worst and
honestly like
august september october that's when you
gotta watch for hurricanes because
that's what it's like
the hottest i was gonna say this morning
it's wednesday right yeah
yeah it's wednesday i have not seen
mr mcguire otherwise known as path kitty
since last thursday
i kind of worry but
then i was thinking well the last time i
saw him last thursday
he seemed in really good shape he had
gained some well no he had
gained some weight i couldn't feel his
ribs anymore
so somebody's been feeding him like i've
been feeding him i know some other
people have been feeding him too
also his fur seemed like it had been
groomed
it was real it seemed um because before
when i would pet him it seemed a little
bit oily like sweaty because you know
how long
like when pookie runs around on the
porch and she gets kind of like stinky
and sweaty
yeah um he seemed kind of like that like
his hair seemed kind of like coarse and
dirty
um when i saw him thursday he seemed
like really really soft really clean
all of the hair that uh was matted on
his sides
that had all been cut off and it looked
like the patches of skin like it looked
like some hair was growing back
so he looked like real good yeah and
when i was coming up to the bench he was
like yelling like hey
you i haven't seen you in a long time i
was like hey man what's up and so
the fact that i haven't seen a lot i
hope that the people that live in that
house
are letting him live inside maybe and
maybe that's why i'm not seeing him
outside as much because i
see him like every day yeah maybe
they're letting him live in the house
now
maybe maybe it's different people
somebody told me
no he was a barn cat well he was but
somebody told me
when i was out there petting the cat
they said oh we heard those people left
and new people came
maybe maybe they took him so i don't
know if those are different people
we were just talking about you so much
yeah she heard us talking so i don't
know if those are different people and
they just decided
we're going to keep them inside and i
hope that's true yeah
i'm going to prove to y'all that elvis
presley was goth
there's there's elvis there's elvis and
melanie
i'm gonna show you how he [ __ ] his
look did evolve he did know about that
[ __ ]
okay let me show you so that was in the
50s
phil says are you sure he's not a ghost
cat no he's not a ghost cat other people
have uh
seen him too and i've talked to other
people on the path about him
look at that [ __ ] he's that is a guy
he's pissed his [ __ ] you know
what i have a belt that's
that looks almost exactly like that yeah
okay i'm gonna [ __ ] find some guys
[ __ ] that was real
what what's going on well i don't know
i don't know invest in a 20 rechargeable
neck fan from amazon which okay i don't
it doesn't really help though the thing
about florida heat
is that i
seriously i don't know how people lived
here without air conditioning i just
don't i just don't
the population was a lot smaller well
yeah
largely they didn't yeah people really
didn't start moving here in numbers
until the early
1970s yeah when disney world opens right
and they started building [ __ ] with uh
air conditioning residential air
when my grandparents my grandparents
moved
to uh daytona
or holly hill which is like a little you
know outpost of daytona
they moved here in 1958 when they bought
their house
um which was one of only four houses in
the neighborhood
it's like a big neighborhood now but
they were the first four houses
um nobody put central air into the
houses
and i don't think they had any air
conditioning for quite a while
they put a window unit in later um
and as long as i you know my whole
childhood
her house was heated it was cooled by
this
one window unit which was in the dining
room
so during the summer you could not sleep
in the back bedrooms
of the house and it wasn't a huge house
just a regular sized house
you couldn't sleep in the back bedrooms
it was too hot so you had to sleep
everybody had to sleep like on a big
pallet
in the you know formal living room which
is right across from
the little dining room like the kitchen
because that was where
the window unit was you couldn't sleep
in the back
it was too hot and you couldn't leave
the windows open because then
you'd be uh infested with cockroaches so
yeah central uh central heating and
central air conditioning changed the
face of the south the population started
to grow a lot
just because it was just so much easier
to live here
to survive i mean technology has allowed
mankind to you know to [ __ ] spread
into [ __ ] arctic regions
in places we're probably not supposed to
be
you know lead to living on the bottom of
the ocean floor
you know it's that kind of crazy [ __ ] no
thank you i was like honestly i watched
especially after watching that mysteries
of the deep show yeah
i hated the ocean anyway just i grew up
literally right next to the ocean i grew
up in daytona beach i was riding the
beach side
and the ocean always scared me and
watching that show i was like okay i was
right to [ __ ] feel that way because
not only there [ __ ] sharks
and various other giant sea creatures
that are there
but one of the episodes we're talking
about a bacteria
what's that flesh-eating bacteria yeah
yeah hold on there's no i don't want it
see look at that that's [ __ ] black
velvet you telling me [ __ ] you telling
me to [ __ ]
elvis wasn't [ __ ] god do you know all
about that [ __ ]
you could wear that nowadays nowadays
yeah
um yeah so they had that uh bacteria
and it killed some people and it was
almost all
in florida some flesh-eating bacteria
and not all the people were swimming in
the water some people were just like
fishing or were like in a skiff or
whatever and they didn't like even get
in the water
um you can also get it from eating
shellfish
it's like not super fun so one of the
reasons that
you know i was like that's yet another
reason why i want to stay in the [ __ ]
ocean because
i was staying out of the ocean anyway
because i want to be eaten by something
bigger than myself that's like
that's something that i would really not
i would really rather not
die like that i don't want to be eaten
by another organism you're so funny
jenny
i'm just saying it's a thing that i have
it's a thing that i have
yeah of all the ways that i don't want
to die
that's probably like top of the list or
very near top of the list i don't want
to be eaten by something
because that and i don't want to know
that i'm being eaten by something ooh
i don't know that's just giving me
[ __ ] nightmares i don't want to do
that
i don't want to be i don't want to fall
from a great height that's probably
second
there's a lot of ways i don't want so
some ways i don't mind dying but it's
like those are kind of like
you that's way up there way up there
anything to do with the ocean like i
said you watch that [ __ ] you watch
what was that show we used to watch i
shouldn't be alive yeah whoo
yeah don't ever go into the ocean for
any reason
nope honestly and some of the ships
well some of the [ __ ] too is like was
not even in boats because one of the
shows
they said oh hey guess what you don't
even have to be in a boat
you could also be in a plane over the
ocean
and if some [ __ ] methane pocket
decided to like explode while your plane
was going over
you would also be [ __ ] so
not only do i not want to go on a boat
on the ocean i do not want to fly over
the ocean
because [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
i don't like it not one bit i'm just
gonna like [ __ ] stay here on the
land if you don't mind
[Laughter]
like i said i grew up next to the ocean
i know how [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
and i don't uh i don't particularly want
to die like that so dom checked out
we'll see you around don
what do you have to go or you just got
sick of our [ __ ] victor says i heard
elvis was a power bottom
no he went a power bottle no he was
straight you're
you're not fun he was straight yeah he
says man that's almost marilyn manson's
style
[Laughter]
yeah phil says my fear is fire and
drowning yeah neither one of those is
fun either
i'm just saying i don't want to like i
don't want to be eaten by
a shark or swallowed by
a whale or whatever nothing like that i
want to be eaten by a crocodile or an
alligator no thank you
i just don't i don't want to even be
eaten by a land animal i don't want to
be eaten by a bear
like that dude from grizzly man yeah
[ __ ] that i don't i don't want that to
happen
so that's kind of that's probably number
one i don't want to be eaten
by anything yeah that's my number one i
don't want to die like that
second one i do not want to die
by falling from a great height either
off a building
off a bridge off out of an airplane
yeah no thanks yeah i think that's
probably one of the main reasons i don't
like flying
it's not so much that i don't like
flying in an airplane i don't like the
feeling of like
if i fell out you know what i'm saying i
don't like heights
so that's my second ways i don't want to
die
yeah yeah they're in there talking about
elvis
t maniac so
all right you have to understand
southern culture
and the music scene at the time was
elvis a cultural
appropriator uh no not really
um he grew up in the south mississippi
and tennessee
rock music was already breaking
kind of like um the racial barriers of
the time
and uh so was gospel and
he was using both of them but so was
other so were other people
he had a lot of black friends he was
friends with a lot of black artists
and he forced a lot of his venues
in the segregated parts of the south and
not all the south was segregated depend
on the county it's a lot of [ __ ]
details that you had to look into um
he forced some of those venues um
to accept his background singers and
other people
he wanted to play with into those venues
so
uh he also contributed a lot um
to um black artists right um becoming
uh well known little richard being one
of them
so uh he had a lot of black friends uh
especially um
james brown all right
so it wasn't so much appropriation it's
just that he was riding a wave
rock music was already breaking
boundaries before elvis got involved
just that it was more underground he
helped make it kind of
come into the mainstream well
yeah that was gonna happen anyway that
always happens
and it kind of happened with rap too
it's just
the way it is um especially in the
united states
now um uh
sophie was talking about his drug use
sophie kind of understands it
he was being prescribed this stuff so
that justified it to him
he didn't like drug culture in the
mainstream like the beatles and [ __ ]
like that he didn't like them
you have to understand that elvis was
was a military guy and he was a very
common type of dude for the south of his
of his time very patriotic most of his
songs were about uniting north and south
and black and white he was
he would do these live things where he
would play battle him of the republic
which is a northern song and then he'd
play
then he'd do dixie and then he would go
into [ __ ]
kind of like gospel and then he would go
into rock
and it was he was trying to be a unifier
in a country that he saw he thought it
was breaking apart back then
especially during the culture war of the
60s
so he was trying to he he kept saying he
was trying to heal the united states and
bring all these people together
which i think he kind of helped do to a
certain extent
um
he he was a good dude uh but you have to
understand
the framework from which he is working
out of
he didn't like the beatles he thought
that it wasn't
a competition things per se like dj's
saying
like oh he just it was he's trying to
defend his career not really
by the time he was doing that he was
already kind of like resting back on his
laurels
he was already recognized it's just that
the new
british wave was starting to hit america
and elvis saw it as un-american
he didn't think it would he he didn't
think it was
traditional elvis was traditional
basically
he was you oh and and he was very
much kind of um
average southern guy of his time
if you want to factor in the fact that
he was artistic and creative and very
popular
most southern guys really weren't on
their own but he was he was trying to
he was very proud of southern culture
and american culture
he did he was afraid he did not like
communism at all
elvis did not like communism he thought
europeans were basically communists
especially uh the the uh
the beatles elvis had a military
background
he he knew about propaganda and mind war
and stuff he thought that
he thought that the that that that the
beatles were
coming into the united states trying to
promote a drug culture and trying to
promote
basically communism or socialism or
something and then it would water down
the strength
of america and break it up through i
guess you could say kind of like
identity politics there might have been
something to it but
i i don't think the i don't think so
well i don't well i think that
fear was a re real fear and it was a
real fear but i don't think i don't
think it was
i think it wasn't i don't think it was
based in the beatles
well obviously i don't think i don't
think the beatles were working for the
soviet union they didn't give a [ __ ]
everything no i don't think the soviets
were just a rock band
but you have to understand the mindset
of the time and
him no i do and what he was thinking
a alien force comes over from european
europe
it starts to dominate this scene he sees
things that he don't
he doesn't think is good for the culture
he's gonna think i bet you the soviet
union's behind that
that's what he thought it wasn't though
they were yeah people still do that
yeah it was just it was just the beatles
were just being them
you know yeah they were just a rock band
right there was nothing behind that
yeah they did drugs yeah yeah yeah he
thought experimented with this not the
other but they weren't trying to push an
agenda
they were just a rock band i don't know
if they weren't trying to push an agenda
i don't think they were trying to push a
soviet agenda
but i think they kind of well to the
extent that everyone's trying to push
their owner
they were pushing their own but that's
kind of like not that's not the same
thing that we're talking about he
thought
elvis thought that the soviets were
behind that
no or at least he said that maybe he
knew that wasn't true
but maybe he would say that yeah he
evidently said that to nixon that he
thought that this was
communist right which maybe he thought
he would like he thought
nixon thought that maybe he thought he
was trying to get into good grace
because evidently he told his friends
afterwards he goes
i got a couple jabs in on the beatles
that's what he [ __ ] told his friend
because i was yeah so maybe he didn't
really think that he just thought
nixon thinks he's practical he's an old
square white dude
people yeah so the fact that he thought
that was
you know so and and and and at that time
evidently when this movie is happening
elvis is trying to get a badge of out
a real badge out of the [ __ ] nixon he
doesn't want
a fake [ __ ] badge that you settle the
tourists
he wants a real special detective
[ __ ] fbi badge
that's that's evidently what the elvis
surviving friends
said he was saying i'm going to go
undercover
and i'm going to [ __ ] break up all
these drug rings
uh he what elvis was on drugs i mean did
he really think he could do that
it's hard to say you got to see the
movie maybe
i think what it was it's under the
influence of drugs it kind of he kind of
seemed like a good idea got away with
him the the [ __ ] ploy got away with
him maybe he started thinking i kind of
feel like i could do it it seemed like a
good idea
yeah i kind of feel like that's what i
hate to break this news to people but
elvis had a huge ego well
most of us had a [ __ ] huge dude how
could they not
elvis would believe that he could do
anything okay yeah
because he could because he was really
really famous and he was really rich he
from his point of view he had a
fantastic track record of getting
whatever he wanted
so it always worked but it always worked
before so when you're talking about it
not now this is something that yeah i'll
go in there and i'll infiltrate a group
of hippies and
i'll find the whole drug ring i'll bust
them all we'll see that's why
we talked about this before that's why i
think that he probably really did think
that he could do that he said he was a
master of disguise and he could go
undercover and they were right because
like i said up until this point you have
to imagine
it had been decades and decades he's one
of the most famous people on earth he's
one of the richest people on earth
and to a large extent he's been allowed
to do whatever pretty much whatever he
wanted yeah
he literally is a king so i kind of feel
like
he got to a point where well it's like
whatever thought came into his head
i could do this thing he probably
believed it he probably believed that he
could do that too
because up until that point he hadn't
been proven wrong a good
a good modern analogy would be kanye
west
kanye west thinks that kind of [ __ ] too
kanye west thinks he can do just about
anything
now can kanye west do anything no
well no yeah yeah but you could probably
but
if you caught kanye on the right day he
could probably tell you that no i could
fly by flapping my hand i mean if you
have a lot of money
yeah and are you famous yeah you can
get away with a lot more than
some dumb [ __ ] like make it get
away yeah that's for sure
but you know so that's why i'm saying
and we kind of talked about this when we
talked about uh
you know elvis and nixon i do think
that elvis legitimately thought that he
could have
like an undercover badge and he could go
undercover and do like whatever he
wanted to do
because up to that point he pretty much
had been able to do whatever he wanted
to do
so i kind of feel like he did have a
framework
and i can't imagine what that's like um
but i can see how that would happen
because if you're used to
most of your life just having
money and power and fame and you can
just like do whatever you like people
just
count out to you and you can just kind
of do whatever you want
i can see how you would get like
delusions of grandeur and you'd be like
oh i can do this on the other thing
because you've gotten away with so much
in the past so i do kind of feel like he
legitimately did think that he could
that he could like infiltrate [ __ ]
hippies and drug race like that people
wouldn't recognize him and [ __ ] like
that i don't i don't know
if he like thought about it to that
extent but i don't know
i i do feel like he believed that he
could really do that now
did he really believe like the beatles
were communist infiltrators
i don't know if he believed that but i
think that he believed
that nixon believed it and i think that
might be why he said it
um but i don't know maybe he didn't
really think that
there was a lot of that mindset going on
at the time
because like i said i kind of feel like
and this is something that i struggle
with all the time because i kind of feel
like humans have a thing where
we kind of evolved to find patterns and
things
so anytime something happens it seems a
little weird or anomalous or whatever
we're always kind of like looking
for the reason behind it there had to be
a bigger reason behind this
but most of the time there just isn't
there isn't
so the fact that the beatles come along
they're like [ __ ] massively popular
they're not american they're british
whatever it's like all these kids are
into it and it's like then they're into
drugs and all this other kind of stuff
so i can see i don't find it crazy that
elvis might have actually believed that
they were communist infiltrators
did i don't know he might have believed
it because i feel like that wasn't a cra
it was a crazy belief at the time but it
wasn't that
fringe you know what i'm saying yeah it
wasn't that fringe of belief
but as i said it's just like any other
time it's just kind of like that thing
where
people can't just let things be oh
something's weird or something is
anomalous or something oh
these people got famous there's too
famous there must be something behind it
most of the time there's nothing behind
it it's just kind of like
[ __ ] just happens [ __ ] just happens and
i think people have a hard time
dealing with that so they always kind of
like have to have some kind of intention
behind it and most of the time there is
not enough
maniacs maniacs calling [ __ ] elvis a
hypocrite i think
over the drug things where he's trying
to bust people with drugs well see
that's what i said too
but the thing is the thing is those
you're reading too much you're reading
too much
into elvis into elvis okay
elvis was going he went to go see nixon
he was tripping balls
on drugs okay we'll see it's not drugs
if a doctor says it's okay well i think
there's more to it than that too
okay he's tripping drugs he's tripping
balls
on prescription drugs and he thinks
drugs are a huge threat to america
and he wants to be dea agent and go out
and basically
stop drugs from being sold
to the american population he also wants
that damn badge at least that's what he
told his brother his his buddies
there's a bunch of [ __ ] different
lines of [ __ ] that he's telling
different people okay i think part of it
was is that elvis knew that he was
addicted to drugs
yeah and he saw drugs as a threat
not only to other people but to him to
himself so he was
trying to [ __ ] stop drugs
from getting into him to him was part of
it
and maybe he wasn't self-aware enough to
realize that
there's it's not hypocrisy it's the
human mind
works in very strange ways it does
there's
i think at a subliminal level
he's trying to kick his drug habit
if he has a dea badge that might help
him
fight off the drugs that are within him
that sounds kind of
yeah that sounds kind of like plausible
it's almost kind of like
magic that's because that's kind of like
the way yeah like magical thinking
and that's kind of like so you so dj is
doing kind of what
i guess you know somebody might do is
well he's being a hypocrite you're
reading too much morality into it
this is totemism it's like it's almost
like religion
if i can get a dea agent's badge
i can get off these drugs all right
i gotta tell my friends that i want it
from a bad collection i gotta tell the
president i'm gonna try to save america
from drugs
he's gonna he gave everybody and then
the movie shows it
every he gives everybody a different
reason why he's doing this okay the real
reason
was subconsciously he he knew that he
was
not even subconsciously he knew he was
addicted to drugs he couldn't admit that
that would be admitting weakness okay
there's magical thinking involved if he
can become an anti-drug
agent he will kick his drug habit that's
what i think it was
as a southern man victim of magical
thinking myself on occasions
that's what i think [ __ ] he's going
well people have if you don't have
a lot of um experience or background in
critical thinking
right human brains are not built to be
logical um they're logical in some forms
but i and i feel like they're not really
um
i've experienced this myself but it's
they're not really meant to be
like uh all that self-reflective i've
felt that like a lot of people are not
that self-reflective because i've
i've met some people that criticize
other people's behavior for doing the
same [ __ ] that they're doing
yeah they know they are at a certain
level doing that and i feel like
deep down maybe not like up front but
deep down they know that they're doing
that
and some part of their brain is saying
we need to like compensate for this
somehow
so i kind of feel like this because you
see this a lot
in people that um you know
they're talking always talking about the
drug culture and like oh these
crackheads and this that and the other
and then you find out that they're
addicted to like oxy or some like
[ __ ]
you know something that's been
prescribed to them
because prescription drugs are
apparently not the same as street drugs
even though
it's it's all along a spectrum and
they're kind of the same so i don't
really
get this whole oh like [ __ ] on drug
addicts
when you are also on drugs well i don't
think any drugs should be illegal i
don't even think you
well yeah i don't know the reason why
they're doing that i don't either
they're trying to get doctors into the
loop they're protecting the careers
i mean i don't really see any
distinction between
someone that is you know cooking crystal
meth or whatever
and somebody that's addicted to oxy
which a doctor prescribed but they have
money so they can have as much of it as
they want
there is really no distinction between
those two things and the fact that
somebody would make a distinction to me
that seems like they're
compensating right there's a there's an
american concept of that
all this stuff has to be controlled
because if not then people will just go
and buy it
well what do you think they do in other
countries they just can't buy it
i don't really see a problem there's no
problem you know thailand you can
basically
buy anything i don't really see a
problem with it and they don't want that
because
the profit goes away you can buy all
these weird ass [ __ ] drugs including
all these hormones
uh for very cheap because there's not a
lot of profit in it for them there's a
very little markup
and there aren't any doctors in the loop
so you don't need a doctor
to [ __ ] write you a prescription the
the american
medical association would [ __ ] a [ __ ]
brick
if you could just go into a pharmacy
environment i mean like to say they're
like oh where's your
gut as long as your person's like
age as long as they're 18 plus whatever
and as long as all is like look
this is all the side effects this is
what the drug is going to do as long as
it's all there
you can read right you can read all of
this okay then we will sell it to you
they don't
if you're an adult and you can read then
you should be able to they don't want
people med
self-medicating because that will cut
the doctor out of the profit loop
which is exactly what happens in most
other countries they go i'm having a
heart palpitation
or this and that i think i'm having a
heart attack yeah this is the this is
i you know there's something wrong with
my heart you know what i mean and you
could probably diagnose yourself as well
as a doctor
and go i'm going to try that drug and
see if it gets better you just go there
and buy it he goes yeah it got better it
must been right
there's a lot of [ __ ] that on the
symptoms you can end up diagnosing
yourself i mean to a certain age pretty
much every time i've gone to the doctor
to get a damp prescription for something
i already knew what i had
i knew what i needed and that's what
they prescribed me
yeah and they don't want that because
they spent all this money on these
educations
they want their money back you know so
but not
most doctors most of them not all of
them surgeons and [ __ ] but you know
most of them are basically glorified
drug dealers you got to go through him
in order to get the drugs
sophie says i'm insanely self-reflective
to a detrimental point probably i am too
probably
but elvis wasn't elvis i don't see he i
don't he wasn't a hypocrite he wasn't
even a bad man everybody who knew him
i don't think he thought about it that
way you're reading too much into him
i don't think he thought about it he
wasn't aware no
he was it a hypocrisy from our point of
view but
he wouldn't wear that i don't think he
he was actually supposedly a pretty
simple guy
um and uh uh amiable real fun
funny uh you know he was a funny guy
honestly you don't realize him we don't
you see that dude and you don't realize
they say he was hilarious i get that i
can see that
yeah so but honestly to be honest like
as someone that like as sophie said
is very self-reflective to the point
where it's kind of like probably
uh crippling i
i get why i can see hypocrisy
in myself and in others but i get why
other people don't
so i feel like a lot of people their
intentions aren't bad
um because i i don't think a lot of
people are aware
that they're being hypocritical i don't
think they mean it
some people do i'm not giving them a
pass or anything but i think like the
large majority of people i don't think
they realize it
at least from my perspective
it's kind of it's interesting because we
were watching man i'm like out of drink
already
let's have another one yeah we were
watching uh
hoarders again last night i'm watching
the new season of hoarders on netflix
because that's what i watch when i can't
think of anything else to watch even
though it makes me mad
and we watched a couple episodes last
night the first one
was a dude and he was like an old guy
and the old guy he had
this massive house and it was just
chopped full of [ __ ]
and his yard was full of [ __ ] too i
couldn't believe
and it it reminded me of my grandma and
my grandfather so much because my
grandfather was also a hoarder
and he had a whole house full of [ __ ]
and he had a whole backyard that was
full of like old cars and boats and [ __ ]
like that
this guy had that too uh i don't even
know it wasn't a massive property but he
just had all this stuff he had like
[ __ ] lumber and
thank you and cement blocks and he's
just like he had it all organized to be
fair
uh because he thought he was gonna like
do something with it someday because
that's what they all think
and um the thing about this dude
his wife uh who he'd been married to for
like 50 years right it was 50
years she had gotten parkinson's so he
was like taking care of her and she was
in this [ __ ] [ __ ] hole where they
lived which would used to be a nice
house
and now you could only there was a
little pass you could move around
so he had like kind of maneuver his poor
parkinson's ridden wife threw this
[ __ ]
horde like to the one couch that you
could sit on
it was just like it was [ __ ]
horrifying the thing about this dude
was that he had every intention
he realized what his problem was
they talked to him before the crews got
there
and he was like new dude i know it's
like my wife has parkinson's this is not
cool for her
we're like sleeping this place is
[ __ ] rats it's like this big [ __ ]
deal
she can't move around we need to get
this cleaned up
and he was very he's like i'm ready
we're gonna do it
and what did i say like as soon as he
said that i said as soon as they start
taking [ __ ] out of his house he's gonna
flip
out yeah what happened he flipped the
[ __ ]
out yeah worse than a lot of people that
i've seen on that show
yeah because honestly some of the people
on there
everybody on there i want to smack but
him you have to watch because the people
that are the most receptive to that [ __ ]
at the beginning
are the ones that are getting gonna give
you the worst problems when you actually
start carting all their [ __ ] out of
their house
yeah okay hold on let me answer some
questions here all right
t was asking well weren't american
people doing drugs before the beetles
yeah but you have to understand the
mentality of the time and the history of
drugs and or drug control in the united
states
the united states the united states i
guess you could say
historically was a country that did
cocaine and morphine well it was legal
for
it all right uh especially in the old
west
and they didn't need to i mean coke was
legal until what
the 30s 20s 30s right yeah so
i know i've seen some silent movies
where they said hey cocaine
yeah it was legal elvis concept of drugs
is not your concept of drugs
okay that you cannot judge these people
from by modern
terms with these words
if you go into the old west
uh okay here's an example [ __ ] um doc
holliday who was a dentist
would sit around with other guys like
wild bill they'd [ __ ] play cards and
go shoot people and they have a big old
thing of [ __ ] cocaine sitting on the
damn
card table and they they didn't snort it
they just put it in wine and drank it
fastest gun in the west yeah they were
[ __ ] loaded okay
most year cowboys that worked on ranches
got injuries a lot
and they used painkillers like morphine
a lot of them were morphine addicts
being addicted to morphine was [ __ ]
real common
a lot of housewives in the 1800s
and i understood it was like almost half
of them were addicted to morphine
you could order it by by mail too you
could just go down the street just buy
it
well like i said it wasn't illegal right
it was totally legal
morphine and cocaine was [ __ ] real
real common until the 1900s
uh it got to a point where it started to
become a problem in society
people were [ __ ] high all the time
somebody's running around rampaging yeah
so they said you could have these things
but they got to be prep
by prescription over time cocaine got
replaced by a new version called
nova cane the new cane because it wasn't
you couldn't get addicted to it as
easily and it didn't quite do the same
things if you snorted it but it
you could still do things like pull
teeth with it okay because they were
using cocaine
to pull teeth dentists use it um
morphine ended up [ __ ] turning into
things like [ __ ] heroin
and [ __ ] um what was the other one
uh well they started with opium and it
became morphine and heroin
uh and now you get it's oxycodone
[ __ ] same [ __ ] it's just
different molecules and companies
started to patent certain versions you
know of all this stuff
the united states was never really
anti-drug
not until very recently the war on drugs
that started what in the 70s 80s
early 80s i feel like 80s was like kind
of the heyday of that
right in the 1800s you had a in the
early 1900s you had something called the
right to bliss which means you had the
right
it was part of a human right to get high
well see i like that
that's a good law now you you're not
driving or like right because you're an
adult
but you had people living in opium den
sitting there smoking opium but never
leaving but oh well
now well that's not my presentation
says most of the drug laws were racially
based only only kind of depending on how
you look
well they were kind of yeah kinda it
depended on which drug it was like for
instance
uh marijuana in california and
everything you got to understand that
everything is by state and county
you can't generalize by country the
union was
didn't exist as you know it it was not
an imperial union
each state had its own laws and each
county had its own laws within that
state
well still it's still like that all
right it's just that that's not that's
not the picture they want to paint to
you on the news
[ __ ] america is still extremely
diverse in what it believes and what it
will do and what it will not do depends
on where you are
uh california was the first state to
kind of go against marijuana
but it didn't it didn't have anything to
do with race per se
it's just that it was coming from mexico
and they were losing out
the the saloons were losing money to
guys bringing that in
they didn't want
buying weed it wasn't made in america
they wanted them
in those saloons drinking drinking and
snorting coke and [ __ ] doing morphine
well it was a similar thing like in
france when everybody demonized
abscess yeah everything wrong with
absence uh and that was mostly wine
manufacturers that would get behind this
oh you can get high
you can see all this stuff from it and a
lot of that was apocryphal
right they just kind of like made up
those stories to get people than not to
scare people away from
drinking absent right so now let's get
to elvis when elvis is talking about
drugs
he's not talking about [ __ ] cocaine
that
that was price nor the cocaine that was
traditional okay
i don't know if he did but he probably
did that was real big in those days
and they wouldn't have seen that as a
drug
i mean that was that was something that
wealthy people did
in the 70s okay and it was they were
open with especially in california
um things like
morphines or opiates and cocaine
wouldn't have been seen as a hostile
drug that's not what
elvis is talking about elvis is talking
about lsd that's what he's talking about
it was the new emergent of properties of
psychedelics
and that freaked people out which is
something because lsd is awesome yes
yeah it was brand new and it made you
see
things and all the solutions so when
when elvis is talking about drugs he's
not talking about weed
he's not talking about coke he's not
talking about more he's talking about
lsd
and that's what and and and i don't even
think he's talking about weed
it's lsd he's talking about because the
uh you know of course
the beatles were big into lsd yeah you
can make some bad ass music on it
that's why they're [ __ ] songs were so
good just ask the cure
that's the lsd inspired [ __ ] right there
okay
like i said don't hate on lsd lsd is
awesome so that's what they're talking
about it's
uh that was a new technology
and a lot of people it seemed to be it
was happening in a culture war
and people thought that the drugs were
causing the culture war not so much that
the culture war allowed for you to take
this
yes see i think it was that sex it was
the other way around people people were
sick of [ __ ] and a new emergent
[ __ ] technology came out and they
were using it
yeah it wasn't that's all it was it
wasn't a thing that was like the drug
that was making it making it happen
right do that right so you can't look at
this from the modern perspective
and oh man them [ __ ] that old dude
that [ __ ] killed all them people what
was his name the one down there to ranch
[ __ ] manson charles manson lsd made
him do it
that's the way they would have seen it
back then yeah which is ridiculous
lsd will make all these people [ __ ]
kill one another and rape girls and
start race wars
that's how they solve it but they say
that about every single drug
right when it comes out during actually
they say that about every single like
technology of that happens right
many times in my lifetime and i'm only
almost 50.
i remember when the drug war started
okay
and [ __ ] a lot of people were like
what the [ __ ] is this all about
why are they worried about this [ __ ]
even the dea drug enforcement
drug enforcement agency was looking at
cocaine and crack and they're like what
are you guys worried about
do we just give them drug treatment this
isn't a big threat
they made it a threat and it had a lot
to do with
making money in law enforcement well i
mean the thing you have to think that in
europe i mean as far as i understand
uh in europe a lot of people around like
heroin and coke and stuff like that
but because they didn't criminalize it
and they went more for like a treatment
treatment
management they're like yo we'll put
them on methadone they have to come
away it's like it's not as big a problem
no
it's not as big a problem it's like
anything else if you look at something
long enough you'll make it more
important than it really is
and you focus on something reality is
what you focus on
if they focused on drugs lot of the drug
war is that you have you have the same
kind of mindset
that was going into like the satanic
panic exactly
um you have old people yeah that
whatever new thing comes along they're
very similar they're
threatened by the very susceptible and
it's like i don't this is a new thing
and i don't like it it must be something
they don't understand it so it must be
something bad
so it's like and the news media had a
lot to do with this
it wasn't just something well because
wanted to do this there was a lot of
money to be made in it yeah i mean
and i don't think the media is trying to
push any agenda other than
what will make us the most money like
what we'll click on
what will people click on what will
people read
people like salacious well
[ __ ] that's true so well yes yes
yes that's true but it's also been more
refined by the time the 70s and the 80s
by the time the 80s came about because
it's all one big click
and you have very rich oligarch families
who know the people that own these news
agencies there's only like four of them
they're like
you know look give them this story and
we'll all make out like bandits
and they pay them to run those stories
you can pay
a news agency to run a story about you
they had
damn uh saudi arabian oil tycoons
buying good press there's you can do it
they they're they're they're pr outlets
and they're very rich
decided that if you made these things
illegal
they would become more valuable and they
could invest in the trade of them
and make money in law enforcement to
fight it so they could play
both sides of that and then the
intelligence agencies got involved
we could now have black funding this is
not a conspiracy theory
okay this is the the iran contra scandal
is what i'm talking about
and they still do it now at the papi
fields in afghanistan
you can make money with that and then
disappear that money into this
into cia and intelligence black budgets
to buy weaponry
to fuel things like to buy things like
stinger missiles and give it to the dam
uh uh uh what do you call them the uh
the the afghani fighters to fight the
soviet union you know that was shit's
all
[ __ ] there they're still doing that
kind of [ __ ] so it's a great source of
money
zach says the psychology behind the
satanic panic
is one of the most fascinating things to
me especially how gullible people
can be this is something that fascinates
me too because i've always been
fascinated by the cult mindset
i guess because i don't know i'm like
i'm like this really cranky contrary
[ __ ]
and i don't like to join anything
um so it's really hard for me to
understand
why anybody would be sucked into a cult
i understand that it's very
common and i'm not like [ __ ] on
people's intelligence or anything like
that for doing that
we've [ __ ] on scientology a lot of times
in cults and stuff
um i would never say those people are
dumb per se
but they don't have the same mindset as
me i guess
i don't know i'm not a joiner so i think
that kind of like helps
because i think most people are joiners
they want to like belong to something i
don't
um i want to get as far away from other
people as possible
so i so i don't think i'm in danger of
uh
joining a cult but i don't know we'll
see daddy rolling fo
uh danny rowland ghostface says that we
should do a paranormal show on the
infamous
huskah castle someday do you know that
one
i don't think so yeah
but yeah it's just i don't know it's
scientology especially fascinates me
because i
knew a lot of them yeah because i worked
for them for a long time
and it was an interesting
uh experience like psychological
experiment for me because i lived there
in clearwater for eight months nine
months something like that
and i worked for a company that was
owned by them it wasn't it wasn't a
scientology org or anything but it was
just like a regular
publishing company it was owned by them
and being around them all the time
was um was very instructive
yeah um did i ever want to join them at
any point no absolutely not
honestly it made me hate them even more
being around them every single day they
just annoyed me more and more and more
every single day
uh until i just had to get away from
them forever
because i'm like look i don't i don't
know i can't be around people like that
grampus is talking about lsd and
flashbacks and somebody chimed this has
never had a flashback
um look i think tila was saying like
that the flashback thing that by today's
today would be
might be a little bit of a myth
i think myth never heard of it now
there's a lot of stuff that happened in
the 60s with lsd
lsd was uh there's a the military did a
lot of trials with it because it has
there's a lot of things about lsd that
has a very good profile to be
a chemical weapon because lsd doesn't
have an overdose point
you can so there's no way to kill a
person with it
um you could spray a bunch of it onto a
population that you want to incapacitate
but you don't want to kill them
that would be a good thing to do because
they probably just wouldn't fight
because yeah they just played they just
lose interest in things and you can just
walk
in and you don't have to worry about
killing any of them
now there's a big difference between
lsd use today especially in a clinical
setting and what was happening
in the 60s in the 60s they didn't know
what they didn't know the doses so
for instance like a window pane hit
back in the 60s was equivalent of like
maybe eight
wind hits of today so they were using
way high doses
you didn't the dose doesn't mean to be
that high
um no so in the 60s they were taking
super high doses
um there's a possibility that
that might not be good for you i would
say
knowing about any kind of drugs and
medications less is always better
all right but even the people that were
taking really high doses
they recovered from it um
in general now some of the people that
were taking them might have already been
slightly
uh mentally unstable to begin with
especially if you got people that have
mental problems or schizophrenia
it might make that worse and if you see
a person like that walking around oh lsd
did that to him no
[ __ ] schizophrenic to begin with
well yeah there might have been some
problems
beforehand because i feel like lsd
doesn't cause the problems
no it wouldn't it might exacerbate
problems you already have
right but right blaming the drug is
reductive
and i really don't think that helps
anything i'm gonna go along with ancient
wisdom
granters um lsd is a good
uh drug taken in a religious setting
for uh cell therapy and this matches up
with what a lot of doctors and
experimentations that they did and what
the military found out about
it's basically what indians would do
called a spirit walk
and it's had a introspection
self-analysis
uh you're having a almost kind of like
an out-of-body experience it's very
controllable
i mean that's why i wanted to yeah it
was just it's nice
the problem is that you can't really do
this in an uncontrolled setting you got
to have
at least with experienced people that
won't let you [ __ ] go outside
you want to stay indoors for about 12
hours you want to be in a safe
environment
around a bunch of friends you don't want
any [ __ ] in there they're trying to
[ __ ] freak you out or anything it's
just
be very chilled um it is not the kind of
on the upswing it is not the kind of
drug you'd want to do if you were going
to commit a crime
now some guys will do all kinds of drugs
before they go commit a crime this isn't
one of them
uh no it would work against you i can't
see how that would yeah
uh be a benefit right so um
i want to try ayahuasca they say
ayahuasca is even better i kind of need
to but i'm the like the puking is
uh is dissuading me i would i wouldn't
do it in the us
i don't know what what the feds say
about ayahuasca i would go to the
yucatan peninsula go down to mexico
[ __ ] with
with some shaman you know i mean there
are some places where you can go
and you go through the whole [ __ ]
mesoamerican [ __ ] rituals and [ __ ]
and uh you're talking to alien souls
and [ __ ] extra dimensional beings i
mean you're tripping balls
and evidently when you come back
according to joe rogan when you come
back you're just like
oh man that was awesome you know what i
mean and evidently you got new knowledge
now i don't know if it comes from the
subconscious the unconscious
probably the cosmic conscious i think
it's opening up [ __ ] in your brain
yeah i think it's what it probably is
too it's probably coming from the
unconscious which is good and
that's still good i mean that's still
good and you evidently learning from
yourself
about yourself and it's good for stuff
like that
like i said that was the that was the
only reason i was really
only interested in doing that type of
drug i don't
give a [ __ ] about coke i don't even know
because they're like oh you have all
this energy
and like [ __ ] yeah i don't need that
i can make you [ __ ] it's great when
you're and it's like
yeah no i don't want i don't want to eat
it and we didn't work for me
it just made me like more paranoid than
normal which i don't need that either
but when i did lsd
i thought to myself and like i said the
cool thing about lsd
is that it's all the best [ __ ]
about being drunk but without all the
worst [ __ ] about yeah you're not
intoxicated you're still
yeah very lucid yeah and it gives
coordination still real good yeah your
coordination's good well sort of
and it sort of gives you a sense of
oneness with the universe i know that
sounds like hippie dippy but it's like
i can kind of well no i can see how like
all the hippies were kind of like oh
we're all one man that's how
lsd makes you feel especially at the
dosages they were taken
it really makes you feel like and and
the thing that was best about it for me
was that it made
it feel like everything was gonna be
okay yeah
like i was i remember it's real
effective for ptsd
i remember saying well yeah i remember
standing at the
uh our sliding glass door yeah and i was
standing at the sliding glass door i was
standing there and pookie was
like sitting next to me me and her were
like looking out
into the night and i said to pookie i
was like
man we're like all one
thing the universe is all one thing
everything cosmic singularity i so i
told her i was like pookie everything's
gonna be okay
yeah yeah everything's gonna be okay
yeah and that was like a really nice
i never feel like that so it was like a
really nice feeling to have
yeah i really enjoyed it i mean honestly
i felt like
absolute crap the next day
yeah well where's you out wow and i went
to work the next day too and i was like
wow this was like worse than any
hangover i ever had it was the worst
yeah but i would totally do it again
because it was like a really really nice
feeling
yeah but be prepared you really have to
like set aside like two days for the
[ __ ]
because you need like 12 hours because
it takes a long time to come on
and it's it takes a long time to
you know do its thing and then the next
day
you're gonna feel like total crap
yeah you're gonna feel like total crap
so graham's asking what's the best music
to listen to actually
the best music to listen to is whatever
you're in the mood for we listened to
the david bowie 70s bowie i was i told
him to put some [ __ ]
on i listened to i put some nick cave on
because that's my thing i was jamming to
billy idol
live billy idol too uh went back [ __ ]
listen to some aha
80s stuff that i liked um
it doesn't really matter it's whatever
you're in the mood to you don't have
you're in the mood for you don't have to
restrict yourself then
you'll know as soon as it starts kicking
in you started like a half hit
first when you cut the paper it's half
of it let that go and you go okay i see
what this is and then you take the other
half
that's sometimes how you can judge how
strong it is gotta remember you gotta be
in a secure environment when this is
going on
this is a religious experience it's not
yeah take it like take it seriously yeah
it's not a it's not it's not for um
uh what do you call it it's not
recreational it's education i would not
drive on it
no uh i would not go out on it i know
some people do
uh recommend it i i would not and i
would not recommend it
if any emergency happened you would not
react to it the right way
no yeah no no you want to stay at home
and uh around friends and [ __ ] and you
know internet really was [ __ ] awesome
on it i was like oh yeah yeah i can see
anything now oh wow look at that
although i was trying to like type i was
trying to talk to uh i have a friend
that was that
was very interested in it and so i
wanted to tell her what i was
experiencing like in the moment
so i tried to like facebook message her
but my laptop
kept like breathing it did well
you guys sort of you kind of it was
going like it was distorting
yeah but it's not you know it's not
happening well i know it's not happening
but i was still having a hard time
typing because i was like man it was
like
the [ __ ] keys are going in and out i
couldn't [ __ ] this was years back
that this happened so finally i just had
to call her
she kind of was [ __ ] with me a little
bit i had to i had to get up and [ __ ]
keep babysitter a little bit because she
want to go outside and i was like no and
she
wanted to go outside and be a werewolf
yeah and
dig around the guard and says no you
can't i wanted to go dig in the garden
yeah
after you've done it a couple times you
you can trust yourself
but what was kind of one of the things i
was doing is i was sitting cross-legged
on the floor
looking at a piece of carpet in front of
me and i was just kind of
going down into this swirling ball of
[ __ ]
almost kind of like a dimension to
another [ __ ] her
doorway to another dimension was
happening and i could feel all this
pulling on me down into this damn
[ __ ] swirling ball
and she kept coming at me hey i'm like
man stop [ __ ]
stop [ __ ] with me stop [ __ ] with
me
you did that a couple times you don't
remember it probably i was getting i'm
getting stuck in this
damn ball get him out of me getting but
then i forgot about it
went away i said okay [ __ ] this [ __ ]
because i had to go deal with some [ __ ]
because you'll just sit there and zone
out on just one object
if you close i tried to do that but i
couldn't if you closed your eyes
everything was like well i did that but
close your eyes you'll vanish off into
another world well because i was hoping
to because like i said i'm a writer i
want some like [ __ ] ideas
and stuff yeah but i was too into
i was running all over that i was
feeling the walls i'm like
feel what the walls feel like this is
amazing and it's like then
like i went out in the living room and
well in the kitchen one of the things
that i noticed like i said
it's you know that you're on something
so you know that it's not real
it's like a really weird it's very very
hard to describe if somebody hasn't
done it but it's like you know that it's
not real
but at the same time it kind of looks
real yeah you know what i mean but you
know it's not
it's a it's a very convincing and kind
of pleasant
visual distortion yes so it's so
because you know it's not real you can
just enjoy it you can just be like oh
look at that [ __ ]
yeah it was like that screensavers on
the television you know yeah and they
were like
pulsing and like pulsing look how
beautiful that is
it's like because we had like this
screensaver on the television that was
all like kind of [ __ ] it was like
like a tropical joke flowers and it was
like it was moving
it looked like it was moving and it was
like like look how beautiful that is and
like we went to
like in on the oven there's a clock on
the oven
and i told i went in there and i told
him i was like the clock
is chinese characters yes i knew it
wasn't
i knew it wasn't but i said it looks
like chinese characters
but it was like regular yeah so so it
was like that kind of [ __ ] and like i
said
i went around like feeling the walls
because the walls
felt really like [ __ ] awesome like
kind of like
tactile you liked all this tactile like
it's kind of furry but like kind of
i don't know it was like it was neat
yeah it's kind of funny to watch her go
through it because that was some
that's like it's like that on the on the
first time you trip
yeah you're like blown away by these
little things but then after like the
second third time you're you're bored
with that already
you're trying to [ __ ] go like well i
tried to do that and it's like it didn't
really work out and then like i
i opened my eyes and then on the bed i
saw a bunch of lizards
running like i knew they weren't there
yeah right i knew there weren't like
lizards in the bed
they're like waking dreams it's like
your imagination is so strong so i was
like oh look at all the lizards and they
were like lizards
like running around like for the [ __ ]
and that was like cool and
like i said me and pookie were like
watching like the stars outside and i'm
like look poopy
it's like it's everybody's one he's
watching he's watching these 70s bowie
videos
he's singing he's dressed up as ziggy
stardust he's [ __ ] singing to me
we're making eye contact through the
screen and i know what he's feeling and
[ __ ]
we're like best friends and [ __ ] yeah i
know he's talking about he's singing
just to me nobody else is seeing this
you know i mean you're going off into
this
one little thing and then you're like
listening to the lyrics and you're
in you're you're you're finding like
what you think are hidden messages to
you and the lyrics
which that's really kind of what manson
was probably talking about with
the beatles were talking to him yeah
that's you know that's what he's talking
about
but you're going through this [ __ ] but
if you're experienced with it you know
it's illusion
you're just enjoying it well i don't
know this was only my first time and
i knew that it wasn't yeah that's what
i'm saying that's why it's hard to
explain to people because it's like you
know
like you see it like it's real but you
know it's not real yeah
you know it's not real yeah it's like
lucid dreaming
right like i know bowie is not talking
to me or singing to me
well yeah that's what i mean like we
knew at the time yeah yeah david bowie
is like not looking directly
it's not looking at you and singing at
you it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter right and that's
the thing like i knew
the clock on the oven wasn't in chinese
i knew that the [ __ ] on the tv wasn't
moving i knew that [ __ ] wasn't happening
i knew i wasn't a werewolf
but it doesn't matter at the time i
guess
i don't know it's like a weird like
thing to like i said it's the best thing
about being
best stuff about being drunk without the
worst stuff about being drunk
yeah you don't get the blackouts because
i still like vividly remember
[ __ ] man i've been drunk sometimes going
to the club and i remember [ __ ] about
the whole entire night
it was just like a blank they're talking
about the tingle up in your spine yeah
you get the weird tingling feelings
everywhere
i remember we were listening to bowie we
were listening to
uh billy idol i told him to put some
nick cave on because i'm into that [ __ ]
and then like i listened to a couple
nick cave songs i remember like walking
back and forth across the room and i was
like doing the [ __ ] with my hands and
stuff
and he's like man we have to turn this
off this too like depressing or
so you said something like that and i
told you i was just like man this is
[ __ ] i'm not depressed like stop it
yeah you made me turn off like the [ __ ]
i don't know
you don't want to really look in the
mirror too much you don't want to look
at another person for too long
they'll start to get kind of distorted
looking although i looked in the mirror
i
looked that always kind of bothered me i
looked at this um you
just looking at objects it's a lot more
comfortable if you look too long at
other people you might see things that
you
just look funny my laptop looks but you
can't but you can't
you don't you don't get hung up on it
you're like
okay i know what that is because you
you're aware that there's distortions
happening and what in your perception
it's about perception it's not so much
vision your vision is normal it's just
how you're interpreting the vision has
changed
yeah like you know you look at a pack of
marbled cigarettes and go god
damn that's red i didn't realize that
red was that red yeah it's just red as
that is that's
just heightens everything yeah he said
that's so red i could taste it
look how sharp those [ __ ] angles are
in that thing
and then you look at a person you go god
damn i didn't realize that that person
was that tall
you [ __ ] that person's tall everything's
kind of exaggerated
yeah that's all it is and like i said
you know that you're not
seeing things that aren't there
necessarily you just interpret them
differently
you're just seeing them in a different
light
yeah i guess is the best way to well
your imagination also gets kind of laid
over certain things that you're looking
at yeah
it's hard to tell differently well you
know that that's imagination
over something that you're seeing but
you get caught up in it you just kind of
go yeah
yeah the lizards yeah [ __ ] right well
that's what i mean
everything like to me it just seemed
like everything
was heightened like everything was more
beautiful
the music was more beautiful the walls
were more beautiful
the colors were more beautiful
everything was just more beautiful
that's the superficial [ __ ] though
[ __ ] really once you get more
experience you're more into ideas
you start shifting away from visual and
tactile stuff
to where like you talk you start to
think about more about concepts and
ideas like where everything comes from
or [ __ ] how is it you grew from a
little zygote into a
yeah but i think about that [ __ ] when
i'm sober though and then you go
i'm a you go like i'm a combination of
everything that i learned from my life
but the thing is though is on everything
that i learned the response that i had
to that learning was something that i
chose
so therefore did i create myself
you start seeing you start looking at
this [ __ ] yeah but see i don't need lsd
to think stuff like that i already i
think
stuff like that when i'm so yeah when
you're thinking like that on lsd and
i've said it's laid out in front of you
you might see it as a [ __ ] map
of a bunch of things right but i do that
when i like when i'm not on my lsd
so maybe so maybe that's why lsd had a
different effect on me because it's like
i already think like that
and then you go on like well this is the
interaction i had with that person and
every time i interact with this person
it was like this and this and that you
start seeing a
map of your interactions with a single
other person and you go you know what
this is not this other person oh you
know what they lied to me this didn't
happen over here
sometimes because your subconscious will
start [ __ ] working and then you're
going like
like it's like a dream you start
remembering the things that the
interaction interactions you have with
that person you go i got a feeling that
person is just pretending to like me do
they really i don't think they like me
and then later on you'll find out that
you're
you're this happened a long time ago
this is a reason
but then later on you go oh yeah yeah i
foresaw what that person would do
you start doing you start having weird
abilities to predict what was going to
happen if you focus on it
and it's not that drug it's that drug a
lot that drug
has an effect yeah it's not so much the
drug is just like opening up it has an
effect on them like i said
it's like bringing your dreams into the
waking world right and
the brain is very powerful so you can
start kind of calling on abilities that
you normally wouldn't have in a normal
waking state of mind
well because a lot of people have said
that when they have a problem
yeah that's why they say the best thing
to do is sleep on it because sometimes
in your dreams you'll come up with a
solution it'll work itself out you'll
come up with a solution that's your
subconscious mind
working on [ __ ] when you're not aware of
it so that's the same thing that lsd
does but
just not when you're asleep when you
understand how that [ __ ] works and what
the effects are you understand
why bands like bands like [ __ ]
uh the beatles and [ __ ] the cure came
up with some [ __ ] cool ass [ __ ]
because they were
talking about it and working on it under
the influence of that stuff
and um which like i said that's why i
wanted to do it because it would give me
like
no they say mark zuckerberg micro doses
that [ __ ] and i've seen his eyes
well i've seen a lot of people that's
kind of like a thing
that dudes no it's kind of a thing
nowadays it's michael jackson
a lot of people are doing that now yeah
which i don't even think it's like that
uh clandestine no there's a lot of
people are micro dosing now yeah they're
taking small doses of that for
therapeutics it's not
legal but a lot of people are doing it
and they're not super sure
they're in the ruling class they they
can't be prosecuted they're above the
law
i mean it's just something that and and
honestly i don't blame them for doing it
because it's probably
like super helpful i would think man i
saw mark zuckerberg talking to [ __ ]
congress and that dude's [ __ ] [ __ ]
pupils were expanded to [ __ ] and i think
that dude's also a cyborg a lot of
people might laugh at me but i think
i think he's a cyborg i'm going to laugh
at you it doesn't make
no it doesn't he's got a lot enough
money to become a sideboard
what you do is you put a [ __ ] chip in
your head that you can [ __ ] charge
remotely using that wireless technology
and then it [ __ ] he's got lines that
go up into his [ __ ] eyeball which
allows him to [ __ ] access the inner
internet and see it inside his own eye
without a [ __ ]
screen i believe i believe he's
accessing the internet [ __ ]
searching looking for answers to certain
things or maybe
people are because they say they have
that technology
to project an image inside your eyeball
so it's kind of like you make your eye
into a screen
you would think that they would hide it
better if they wanted to hide it from
everybody though
he's got enough money we didn't have to
hide it i just think he's a sideboard
okay i think he's got a cell phone with
internet access in his head
and he's i think he's using his eye as a
[ __ ] screen maybe he's just a weirdo
with autism
spectrum disorder i don't know i don't
think so i think he's got
quite an i think he's quite an average
guy who lucked into that power
and has a lot of [ __ ] money from
everything i've ever heard about him
when he was a kid he was just kind of an
average dude
and that makes more sense that he's just
average i think most of those people are
just lucky
well luck has more to do with people's
fates than they would like to believe
like elon musk which is [ __ ]
elon musk has a lot of money and a lot
of power he's making a whole space
program but he just seems like an
average guy and
if you look at the women he selects
they're kind of just [ __ ] average
kind of like goth checks
you know what i mean and because who
does he need to impress he doesn't need
to impress anybody he can select any
woman he wants to to have fun
and uh i think he's just kind of an
average guy that has a whole [ __ ] ton of
money
and enough ball balls to go yeah i'm
gonna make rockets
and he just hires people that know how
to do it and it gives them the freedom
to do it
i'm gonna land a rocket on his tail
what's the best way to do it i'll go on
tail that's how we're gonna do it
good i don't i don't think he's any i
think he's above average intelligence
maybe 140 145
well but the thing about it is i don't
even think he's that i don't even think
anybody if you have enough money
you could do anything you can hire
somebody anybody right yeah to do [ __ ]
for you
yes i don't i don't know you don't have
to do it i don't even think he's
educated is he
not in the car i don't think he has
college education i would not presume i
don't think he does i don't have no idea
but like i said if you have enough money
you can just higher education well it's
just like
when i eve [ __ ] man even when i was in
high school i was the poor [ __ ]
yeah but the smart one and then you had
all the rich [ __ ] that were dumb
and they would pay you to write essays
for them because they were too stupid to
write them for themselves oh [ __ ]
what is that it's a [ __ ] palmetto bug
what what oh
no no no oh did you get it yeah i got
the kid
a florida moment just happened yeah a
florida moment
you did get it right yeah you get some
toilet paper
this happens every time i'm in here fast
as [ __ ] every time it rains
all the palmetto bugs are like oh can we
come in your house she said
thanks i'm just like no i'd rather you
didn't
bro he was running [ __ ] fast he's not
super giant
he's not that big he's kind of a smaller
one yeah
don't put it on the shows
um yeah tila says jenny would you take
shrooms with tom one day yeah i would do
that
she wants to know tila says uh she's
asking if we would do shrooms together
one day
shoes aren't as good as lsd no but
that's
it's kind of along the same lines yeah i
bought like a hallucinogen
type of person well they do that it does
that's just not a strong it's kind of
like peyote
i mean you know i've done you know i've
smoked weed i've done coke it's like
[Music]
yeah yeah it's i don't know it doesn't
do a lot for me
it doesn't do a lot for me it's a
palmetto bug is a fancy
word for a it's a flying rope it's a big
old
flying rod they [ __ ] fly yeah they
fly they live in palmetto trees and then
they come in your house
the only good thing about them is that
they can't really infest
they because they're too big they can't
hide
the worst ones are those little bitty
german cockroaches those are the worst
ones
well we had an outbreak of that a couple
years ago yeah but that was easily wiped
out
they've got inside the damn top of the
damn dishwasher
yeah and i just pulled the dishwasher
out and [ __ ] sprayed them
but they were living up in there well
we've since had the
yeah is that a different dishwasher than
what we haven't no same movement
okay same one i thought it was a
difference i had to pull the damn
dishwasher out they were living up on
top of them there was
probably about 50 60 of them probably 70
of them
oh my god that reminds me they happen
fast they happen fast
you just see a roach you know what the
[ __ ] that dude and then you see another
one you go there's they're underneath
there
you open it up in a bit oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was just on top of it the [ __ ]
whole house is loaded with poison i got
the [ __ ] professional sprayers
well you even said last night i said
that this time of spring i gotta spray
again
well it's summer time summertime and i
mean this is the time when all the bugs
are running gotta go around the whole
house and spray on the outside and
spray all the doorways all the [ __ ]
outside the wind the the windows
sills all around you got to make it so
and then like the this
you have to try to get any way in any
any way in or out of the house you have
to spray it
and underneath the garage door because
they
they'll come in underneath the garage
door and then they'll get in the garage
and then they'll come underneath the
[ __ ]
door into the house the florida doors on
a house like this are all double doors
and where they come together at the
floor there's a little space they can go
right in
they can come right in yeah they're
small because there's a little
weatherproof in there but they can just
push that out of the way
so all houses are basically open you
think it's closed
not to a roach that [ __ ] is wide open
they come right in
even big roaches can flatten themselves
down to like nothing
paper sized yeah like paper thinness
snakes can get in the house
just wait we haven't had that too yeah
we haven't had one in the house though
yet
um one time we did
that's right we've had lizards i get
lizards all the time lizards and frogs
come in the house all the time yeah
we've had one snake in the house in 10
years one snake
i forgot about that but i think did
did one of the cats bring that in or did
it just come in
i think they found it i think they found
it like
i'm not really sure because i think
maybe they found it like in the house
and they were kind of like hey
kill it do something about this i'll
wake up in the middle of night with some
kind of ruckus happening and
a cat is fighting something and they're
trying to warn me kill it kill it
wake up wake up let's kill it she's
usually a palmetto bug
so they're good at that and that was a
little one a good palmetto bug is uh
almost two inches long i mean see that's
why like pookie and beige are like
really good about that because if a
if a palmetto bug or like a big bug gets
in the house yeah
they'll attack they will freak out yeah
they will attack it
and then they will come and wake us up
yeah yeah they'll jump you guys
wake up wake up you guys you asked we're
under attack
there is a monster here yeah
[Laughter]
it's funny they're good like that yeah i
mean pookie is very protective
of the house so
a bug gets in she will make a lot of
noise in the middle of the night
i mean we've had like [ __ ] we've had
palmetto bugs
that got into the room at night and
2 3 in the morning i would hear
i'll hear like all this noise and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is that
and you wake up and pookie's over there
by the wall hey
hey hey and then sometimes she'll jump
up in the bed
and she'll like kind of whack on your
chest or whatever she's like look that's
over here over here and there's like
jump over it's like so [ __ ] funny
she's like she's a good girlfriend yeah
they're saying yeah that [ __ ] could
squeeze down
it's like a [ __ ] yeah it's like a
little like
and what's funny what's funny is about
about palmetto bugs
and grandpa says they don't have them in
michigan they don't it's too cold
they can be two inches long but they can
[ __ ] s flatten out to nothing
and then when they're running around
they'll puff up
and they'll even stand up on their back
legs and kind of threaten you sometimes
if they see you
they'll be surprised they'll stand up
kind of like a praying mantis for a
second
you can see the head rotate around and
look at you man it's [ __ ] it's weird
when they're moving and they're [ __ ]
active i guess it's almost kind of
semi-hydraulic
their their blood pressure or whatever
it is that they have for blood
can pump them up to look quite big and
then they'll go to something that
is tiny and they'll flat
crease in between say like cupboards and
they'll flatten out and run inside
and run inside there and go how did that
big ass [ __ ] thing
like in between your your cupboard and
your wall
and the wall how did it get in there
just a minute ago it looked like the
size of a [ __ ] big
praying mantis you know and they're
related to a praying mantis and a damn
cricket there's not a lot of difference
um
you know pretty menace more predatory
but they're more like a cricket
except crickets are a little shy or you
don't see crickets trying to get into
your house
i'm not grossed out by cricket yeah can
i just say
that i have had an experience at least
two times in my life
where there's been a big roach that has
been encroaching in my
living area and i have dropped
a webster's unabridged dictionary this
big
on it and it has not killed it that's
because it was on carpet and it [ __ ]
flattered it no
it wasn't on the floor damn it did not
kill it
i pulled the [ __ ] off and it was just
like
metaphorically it was just kind of like
nope and it ran away
so yeah just get
they they're not they're they're not
like [ __ ] dealing with our [ __ ]
you drop it you drop a dictionary on it
there it doesn't kill them i think mike
i think mike is saying that they're not
cockroaches i don't know what are
cockroaches
crickets aren't cockroaches or palmetto
bugs aren't [ __ ]
people when you say it comment in the in
the [ __ ] comment section
please give us enough context have no
idea what you're talking about
grampner's hammer says palmetto bugs
were everywhere
when i attended the uh fed ellie academy
in brunswick georgia
yeah like on my food tray in the chow
hall and on my towel in the bathroom
yeah
yeah they're kind of everywhere
they're kind of everywhere yeah the
house i grew up in
they're not in all houses but they get
into all houses like i said they well
they will
yeah they they basically it's very
difficult to get an infestation of
[ __ ] palmetto bugs
i mean you have to be real neglectful
they're big
you would see them when you and then you
would kill them
uh the ones that will infest are like
the little german ones
once they come in and you know what i
mean [ __ ] you gotta jump on that [ __ ]
early
or or they'll or you gotta fumigate the
entire house
as soon as you see german cockroaches
you gotta jump on them
well if you see one yeah then there's
there's a hundred a little colony
there there's a colony somewhere you got
it you gotta find them and you gotta
kill
they're smaller but they're everywhere
they get into [ __ ] they're a lot harder
to get rid of
if you especially if you let them go if
you let them go for a month you're
[ __ ]
they're going to be all over the house
you got to get on them on dates yeah
because as soon as you see one you got
to find out where they're [ __ ] and
they make here we were talking about
this last night we were talking about
hoarders because one of the hoarders
uh houses yeah on the episode that we
watched
she was in alabama and her whole house
was infested
with german cockroaches yeah that's a
lot worse and you said oh there's a
smell
and i said uh yeah sorry exactly it's
like a maple syrup it's a maple smell
like a rotten maple smell
and if you smell it in this if you go
into a southern house you get that
rotten
maple smell you go like oh it's a roach
infestation it's rigid
it's a very distinctive yeah very easy
you'll smell it you'll smell it in
abandoned houses because
it the smell does not go away takes a
long time you got to clean the [ __ ] out
of the house
to get that infestation smell out the
people will be gone the roaches will be
long gone
but that smell will will be behind and
it's just
it's sickly sweet [ __ ] like oh
it smells kind of like maple syrup but
yeah it makes you almost want to throw
up yeah yeah
yeah i knew it as soon as he said i was
like i know exactly that's why you're
talking smell it
i've smelled that many times many times
well i used to live like before we moved
in here
i lived in a an apartment over on uh
aluma yeah in uh by
university of florida yeah some of these
old apartment buildings man and that
apartment
yeah even though i wasn't dirty and i
didn't i didn't even i wasn't even there
it was your name yeah but that [ __ ] was
infested with german cockroaches yeah
i think it was the person above me i
come over here to see her
she couldn't leave any food out
everything had to be in the refrigerator
everything was in plastic bags
in the refrigerator and the place would
be spotless
but you'd see a damn little german
cockroach eating the soap
and [ __ ] then you go running after it
and it would [ __ ] run into a wall and
disappear
yep one time i went in there and i was
[ __ ] saying where are these [ __ ]
things coming from
i opened up her uh one day i opened up
her uh
the door to her uh the water water
heater
yeah and saw three of them sitting on a
pipe of the water heater
and running to the damn wall and that
says they're living here this whole
building is infested they're upstairs
they're upstairs next door and they're
inside the walls
and you got you out of there though got
you out of there
well i i bug-bombed the apartment it
would never matter
because the infestation isn't wasn't in
your apartment it was in those walls
yeah and you have a situation in florida
and some of these old apartment
buildings and it doesn't take long
if one person gets an infestation
because they don't take the [ __ ]
garbage out
that building will be infested for
decades decades
because to kill it in those old
apartment buildings
you have to fumigate the entire thing
and to do that you have to [ __ ]
evict everybody and that might be 20 or
30 [ __ ]
apartments yeah and they're not going to
do that because it's going to cost them
200
damn money yeah and then the people go i
don't want to leave my apartment
because you got people that don't give a
[ __ ] about roaches
and you have to put a whole tent around
the whole damn apartment
block and then spray it and chances are
another one of those apartment blocks is
infested
and that infestation will [ __ ]
transfer out to the other ones because
a roach could cross the street that's
all i got to do
well yeah that's why i i'm [ __ ]
skeptical of [ __ ] apartments
uh it makes you want another real
expensive
tall downtown apartment buildings i bet
you they got [ __ ] infestations
but the thing is uh yeah all it takes is
one person it takes is one and they get
in there and they're [ __ ] you can't
ever get them out of them damn
skyscrapers because the thing about well
it was better
like after because like i said i was
lucky because
i worked nights and
i worked in another town so
i wasn't actually in my apartment for a
for several nights a week so i was like
staying with other
people in the town where i was working
or staying with you
so it's kind of like i wasn't in there
probably like three or four nights a
week
so i could afford to like bug bomb the
place
and leave it for two or three days
and then when i came back i was like and
it was better
after that i didn't see any roaches
prior to that i had been like every
single thing every single time i left
i put the coffee pot in a plastic bag
and put it in the refrigerator i put
everything in a plastic bag and put it
in the refrigerator
if i was going to be gone further if
ever if i ever
used a mac 10 i owned an ingram mac 10
and 9 millimeter
back when i was in the service i owned
one sold it though
actually no the mac 10 got taken from me
that's right remember that one
i told that story yeah remember
no no i didn't have the suppressor for
it though
santa is talking about scorpions we have
scorpions here too but they don't get
i've never seen like a super giant
scorpion here but i have seen
little ones yeah now mps took it from me
long story man i don't want to tell a
story again you don't want to tell that
story
had a mac 10. i had it on my motorcycle
and [ __ ] took it through the main
gate of [ __ ] fort campbell
and they they did a [ __ ] search
called a spread eagle they searched your
[ __ ] and they found a [ __ ] mac 10 in
there
i legally owned it it's just that they
said that constitutes carry to conceal
weapon because that was within
arm's reach i said dude i'm [ __ ]
riding a bike i was out
shooting it they confiscated it they
told my [ __ ]
colonel jason kamea he ended up being
like a [ __ ] five
four star general he was in charge of he
ended up being in charge of the whole
afghanistan mission for a while
he called me in [ __ ] dressed me down
why are you doing running around [ __ ]
mac tennis says i legally owned it i was
out shooting and it came in they got me
how am i gonna do it don't you have to
put it in trunks i don't want a car i
got a motorcycle
get the [ __ ] out of here and i said what
about my mac 10 he goes
[ __ ] your back ted
if i never got it back well there you go
yeah
you should get a car with a trunk yeah
yeah [ __ ] your back
so what about my [ __ ] back take your
[ __ ] your back ted
so the mps kept it had it been in a car
they just wanted to keep it they wanted
to keep it yeah yeah
yeah they wouldn't he wouldn't give me a
[ __ ]
inside release to go give to the mp so i
could reclaim my [ __ ] he was like [ __ ]
your back den
they took it [ __ ]
better than getting an article 15 though
and getting reduced right
what's that he's still mad about no i
don't give a [ __ ]
that was at a time when a mac 10 was
kind of rare
but they're not as rare as they are
today and there's still a lot of them
out there but they
they bring in a big price a cobre m119
not quite as much but no i had a mac
ingram uh
military arms corporation ingram mac 10
i had one
well it wasn't all that good though it
was kind of fun but more of a novelty
than anything else
without the [ __ ] sound suppressor
they're not very useful the [ __ ]
recoil and control is pretty
bad mp5 is a lot better good tila says
you all got a lot of lizards down there
too right oh my god
everywhere we have
um all those little animal lizards
yeah anal lizards anal a-n-o-l-e
all right and oh yeah yeah we have a
bunch of those
um those are pretty much everywhere it's
funny because
back in the day when i when i was
married my
uh mother-in-law who had never been here
yeah she came to florida with my niece
at the time she'd never been here she
came for two weeks
and one of the first things she
commented on was that there are lizards
everywhere because they don't have that
in the uk
yeah they've seen it in spain because
there's a lot of lizards running around
but florida there are little lizards
running around [ __ ] everywhere
everywhere um they come out
you don't see them a lot in the winter
but summertime
there's lizards all over the place all
over the place
so yeah we have that everywhere we have
lizards we have skanks
there's geckos of some kind but you
don't see a lot of those
you know what i mean yeah you're all
right getting sleepy what time is it how
long
how long you been streaming almost four
hours yeah it's time to [ __ ] shut it
down
you sure yeah i'm getting sleepy
just pepper says north america only has
two veno spiders black widow
and brown recluse both of which we have
in florida
my brother got bit by a brown recluse
many years ago
got blood poisoning so it's no joke
just saying i've seen both of the
spiders in the wild
but just saying
tom does uh wait falls across the nose
we're talking about spiders okay
you don't even you're not even gonna
like do any wig action or anything
you're not helping me out here no i know
[Laughter]
all right guys you just stopped talking
or yeah
you've gone on for like four hours
starting to get kind of drunk
all right guys well it's good to see you
guys on our birthday
and tomorrow we're going to go yeah
tomorrow we're going to go get
right some food at the buffet
yeah getting these bubbles okay go with
some cake
and yeah and uh it'll be fun
yeah and then we're gonna see you guys
for the may show
on uh friday friday oh i'm excited about
the friday show because
i stumbled across a possible
serial killer that i never heard of
before
yeah what's his name he's called the
coast fiend
okay it's from the 1930s that's what the
show's gonna be about yes
all right i'll look into it yeah are you
supposed to look into
uh not a lot i couldn't find a lot of
the only
video i found on youtube was
one of those shows that's like 13
creepiest mysteries of like american
history or whatever and it was like
it was one of the 13. i didn't find any
like videos of it on its own
okay i only came across it like
accidentally
which is why i put it into because it
was
tangentially some people speculated
that it might be related to the black
dahlia case
because the mo was kind of similar
but honestly it was something i never
heard of and it's like i didn't even
like even all the research i did for
like my faceless villain books i never
[ __ ] heard of this [ __ ]
i don't know if this is an unknown
serial killer if
or if the crimes were unrelated i don't
think they were unrelated but we'll see
it's a fascinating case i'm surprised i
never heard of it but like i said this
is one of the things
you start delving into like unsolved
murders
and you keep finding more ones and a lot
of them are kind of related
so many murders you told me i should
write a book called just so many murders
what do you do i'm talking to somebody
okay he's checked out
so i guess we're going to end it
uh tomorrow we're gonna celebrate tom's
birthday
right yeah yeah
i'm answering somebody on the show okay
all right so hopefully you guys had a
good time
this is a four hour [ __ ] show yeah
and we will see you guys on friday
evening we're going to talk about a
serial killer that like i said i never
heard of which i'm excited about you
gonna say anything
yeah no okay i'm letting you finish the
show jenny where do you want me to
interrupt you
what you usually do come on no okay okay
we'll see we'll see you guys tomorrow
or uh we will see you guys friday
evening
hopefully you guys had a good time we
will see you then
and goodbye